So Leute da bin ich, ich muss noch kurz meinen Pulsel fertig fordern.
Ja, mir ist aufgefallen, dass die Uhrzeit nicht mehr stimmt und dann ist mir gedämmert,
dass hier Zeitumstellung war und dann ist mir wieder eingefallen, wie sieht es eigentlich
aus mit Zeitumstellung Abschaffung, vielleicht erinnert sich der ein oder andere dran, dass
wir vor drei Jahren oder so darüber abgestimmt haben, dass in der EU die Zeitumstellung abgeschafft
wird und da haben auch die meisten Leute dafür gestimmt, aber bis jetzt ist irgendwie nichts
passiert, fragt man sich warum nicht, Zeitumstellung, was ist aus den Plänen geworden, igittweb.de
Alter.
Man konnte sich nicht auf Sommer und Winterzeit einigen, ja ist doch egal, dann sollen halt
manche Länder das machen, manche Länder das, es ist ehrlich gesagt scheißegal, ob wir
EU-einheitliche Zeit haben, ist mir vollkommen wurscht, Hauptsache wir schalten nicht mehr
um, was juckt mich, ob wir EU-einheitliche Zeit haben, dann haben wir halt Schwedenzeit
und Polenzeit und sonst was, ist mir doch egal, Hauptsache wir schalten die Zeit nicht
um, hier 84%, das muss man sich mal echt auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, 84% haben dafür
gestimmt und man schafft es trotzdem nicht und letztendlich ist ja auch die ganze EU-Bürokratie
die letzten Jahre schon immer wieder groß in der Diskussion gewesen, so nach dem Motto
viele sagen ja auch als Schwachsinn braucht man gar nicht und das macht sicherlich keine
Werbung dafür, wir haben Commando dafür, null, ja, das ist so fail, auf der einen Seite,
also dann muss ich das jetzt mal insofern auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, 84% stimmen
dafür, es passiert nichts, dann kommt so Zeug wie Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Uploadfilter
und so ein Geschiss, da würden, wenn sie hätten können, 84% dagegen gestimmt und der
Scheiß ist am Start, das ist doch echt so manchmal der blanke Hohn ey, was ist das
für ein Überleg, Mark, LD, MN, 11 Monate, 1, 2 Hypersubscriber, danke schön für den
Sub, 14 Monate, ok, aber anscheinend hat sich nichts getan, äh, das ist echt der
Witz, es ist mir egal, was der für spricht, die haben 84% abgestimmt, die sollen es jetzt
mal machen, dafür war der Aufschrei ganz schön groß, du hast ja außer, außer von
irgendwelchen offiziellen Stellen, hast du ja von keinem gehört, oh ja, will ich unbedingt
haben, aber da sieht man mal, so Sachen gehen halt schnell, wir können es jetzt auch kaum
beurteilen, weil wir haben ja keine Abstimmung dazu, da gab es ja keine Abstimmung, oh man,
so einen Scheiß kriegt man schnell, ne, aber Zeitumstellung abschaffen, ne, ne, ne, unfähig
erladen, alter, meine Güte, und ich hab schon gehofft, das ist die letzte Zeitumstellung,
kappa, eiler al-kalf, 5 Monate, exellent, Subscription, Massive IQ Boost für den Chat
wieder, so, schauen wir mal kurz das Gedudel aus, oder irgendwas anderes an, oh man, es
ärgert mich, ich soll den Kram abschaffen, so gut es ist, so, schauen wir mal, ob wir
irgendwas sinnvolles empfohlen kriegen, es ist auch noch keiner wach, ne, heute ist wirklich
aufwach im Stream, sind alle müde noch, haha, der Scam-Train auf dem Handy, den kenne ich
gar nicht, mir fällt gar keine, aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich gucke auch selten
hin aufs Handy, mit Chat eingeblendet, das ist mir noch gar nicht aufgefallen, wenn ich
vom Android-Gerät aus gucke, habe ich das eh nicht, ich hab ja eigentlich morgen frei,
das wisst ihr ja, also ich arbeite ja montags prinzipiell nicht, am Morgen habe ich mich
dazu überreden lassen, von glaube 9 bis 11, 9, ne, 10, ach keine Ahnung, irgendwie so
in dem Dreh, auf irgend so eine komische Runde zu gehen, klar kann ich da für Zeiterfassung
eintragen und ich kriege das ja bezahlt alles, und da soll ich irgendwas vorstellen mit noch
jemand anderem zusammen, ja, aber es macht man nicht alles, ne, ja so früh, Vorschlag
300€ Open Source Smart Home, können wir uns angucken, geiles Projekt, ok, mit dem,
das zeigt mal her, gucken wir uns gleich an, zu gut, ja, aber letztendlich ist es sowas,
habe ich ja auch schon mal in einem Video gesagt, gerade in Homeoffice-Zeiten ist es
nicht verkehrt, wenn man sich irgendwie so mal ins Gespräch bringt und auf irgendwelchen
sinnlosen Runden einfach viertelstunde sinnlose Sachen zu erzählen, ist halt einfach plus
stonks, ja, es kommt einfach immer gut an, wobei so sinnlos ist es ja gar nicht, was
wir erzählen, ja im Prinzip schon, im Prinzip ist mehr oder weniger 90% der Sachen, die
auf der Arbeit erzählt werden, sinnlos, jetzt mal so an, an allgemein standardsgemäßen,
wie viele Leute das interessiert, das ist 90% der Sachen, die man auf der Arbeit erzählt,
komplett sinnlos, hier, das ist ein bisschen lauter, können wir es machen, so, gibt es
sonst noch irgendwas, was uns YouTube vorschlägt, was wir unbedingt gucken müssen, das ist
ja schon uralt, das ist, wollte ich gerade sagen, 6 Jahre alt, da gab es auch total
viele Videos von, Windows XP Web Browsen, das haben wir letztens sogar selbst gemacht
in der VM, das muss ich mir kein Video zu angucken, was, die Modern Warfare 2 Server
Shutdown, ernsthaft, ach ne, anscheinend doch nicht, ich meine, dann müssten wir den DLC
Verkauf einstellen, die verkaufen immer noch DLCs für MW2, muss man sich mal vorstellen,
die du überhaupt nicht mehr spielen kannst, weil keine Online, weil keine Spieler am
Start sind, ja, finde ich gut, weißt du, was das nämlich bedeuten würde, wenn wir Vollzeit
gleich 4 Tage Woche machen, das bedeutet, ich muss nur noch 3 Tage arbeiten, das finde
ich gut, da bin ich sofort dabei, ach, haben sie da jetzt ein Video zugemacht, das war ja
vor ein paar Wochen oder paar Monaten schon eine Weile her, in den Nachrichten, dass es
so einen hackbaren Keuschalsgürtel gab, das müssen wir uns mal angucken, ja, aber ansonsten
kriegen wir nix sonderlich spannendes vorgeschlein, das ist Fake News, aber dass die, dass dieses
Ding anfällig ist, ist keine Fake News, das habe ich ja nämlich schon vor über einem
halben Jahr beim Hacker News gelesen, dass du potentiell diese Geräte quasi den Besitzer
aussperren kannst.
Also was ich ja persönlich hoffe, weil es jetzt gerade einer schreibt, ich hoffe ja
mal, wenn diese ganze Geschichte vorbei ist, irgendwann mal, und die Leute sollen wieder
auf die Arbeit gehen, dann hoffe ich, dass man auf sowas rauskommt wie 50-50 oder so,
das wären dann bei mir 2 Tage Homeoffice, 2 Tage auf der Arbeit, das wäre dann eigentlich
ganz cool, Eintagoffice wäre auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, da könnte man dann irgendwelche
Wartungsrunden, Teamrunden, sonst was machen, am besten auch wenn alle da sind, ja, das
ist dann eigentlich nicht so verkehrt, die Musik weiß wieder nicht wie laut sie sein
will.
Ja genau, so sieht es aus, Peek, so sieht es aus, das sind diese ganzen Billig-IoT oder
tja, ist, ist, ist ein App, ein Keuschalsgürtel mit App, ist das ein IoT Device, ich würde
mal sagen, schon, ähm, die Dinger sind ja eh zum größten Teil voll für den Arsch,
es gab ja auch, es gab doch auch mal diesen Talk, wo die Leute einen, ich glaube, was
war das, ich glaube nur ein Badblatt mit App, der überhitzen konnte, wo du dann, wo du
wirklich die Leute sprichwörtlich den Arsch anbrennen konntest, das gab es ja auch mal,
es will es jetzt nicht suchen, weil man weiß nicht, was man da für Bilder findet, oh man,
kennst du Badblacker, ja, das habe ich auch schon gesehen, richtig fail, muss ich euch
mal vorstellen, jemand baut ein, baut ein Gerät, was überhitzen kann und dieses Gerät
ist eigentlich dafür gedacht, sich in Bombe zu stecken, ja, willkommen 2021 Internet of
Shits, alter, nice
okay Leute, mit was fangen wir an, mit was fangen wir an, Stadia, Keg W, Negative Latency,
aber wir gucken uns das zuerst an, kurz die Musik aus, ich kenne den Typ nicht, anscheinend
alter, ist er aber recht bekannt, ich meine halben Millionen Subs, war kurz mein Herzeitenenttoten,
so, passt, nee, ich kenne den nicht, das stimmt, Weiss hat schon viel Stumpfsinn gepostet,
warte mal, war das auch nicht Weiss mit dem How to Build PC oder war das was anderes,
wer war das mit diesem geilen Gaming, Gaming PC Video, nee, das war ein anderer, oder,
wer war ne, Virg, Virg, nicht Weiss, achja, stimmt, er hört sich ähnlich an.
To get a fake story on Weiss, I need to give them the perfect tale for their website, Weiss
called the Cellmate, it connects to the internet so that your partner can control your privates
from their phone.
Alright, how about this, can I get Weiss Magazine to print a story about a how to build PC
on Weiss?
Ich mein man darf nicht vergessen, das Produkt ist wirklich echt, das gibt's, sieht zwar
aus wie ne Mülltonne, ne bisschen kleinere, aber das Ding ist echt, ja, also das gibt's
wirklich.
Alright, how about this, can I get Weiss Magazine to print a story about a hacker who broke
into the Cellmate system and used it to lock my dick and balls in a digital chastity cage
and then refused to let me go until I paid them hundreds of dollars in Bitcoin?
Of course I can, this is Weiss after all.
Now let's get down to business.
Step one, find a Weiss journalist who looks like he would write a story without doing
any research.
That'll be easy, I can pick literally any journalist that writes for Weiss.
That was easy.
Step two, create a fake email, Facebook and Zoom account under the name Sam Summers.
Because I've done this before where I've emailed a journalist, told him a fake story and then
I didn't realize that my real name, Lewis Spears, was in the email.
Okay, thanks, Jim.
And if you search that name on Google, or look for him on Twitter, he's a snack to find.
Both times I've done that by accident, they still run the story, so I think I might be
able to...
Warum sitzt da, warum sitzt da random Typ einfach daneben jetzt?
...too much faith in journalists, but nonetheless...
Und warum hat er so ne schlechte Audioqualität?
...I don't want that to happen this time.
Step three, craft the perfect email to send to a journalist that will definitely make
them want to write a story all about me.
Let's make it even harder for me and sell some tickets while I'm at it.
Can I, during the interview for my fake story, sneak in my new show title, Back in the Trenches,
the name of my venue, Rubber Chicken, the area I'm performing in, South Melbourne, and
for bonus points, the ticket price, after some back and forth over email, Vice journalist
Lorenzo was convinced and he asked to interview me for a story.
Let the challenge begin.
All right, it is 10 a.m.
I'm about to join the call.
Vice wants to talk to me about getting my dick stuck in a cave.
Not the most groundbreaking story a journalist could cover, but, you know, it is Vice.
So, let's see how we go.
Hello?
Hi.
Nice to have you here.
I'm good.
How are you?
Okay, so, yeah, tell me a little bit about, so what happened?
We got the sell made a few months before it happened, it was pandemic and we were like,
oh, we were bored, so we thought we might as well get back in the trenches and try something
new.
Boom, one point for Spears.
Next up, I need to sneak in the venue name, Rubber Chicken.
How do I work that into conversation?
In November, I get a message in the app from just as someone I didn't recognize.
It said something like, your cock is mine, we've hacked into your device and we will
not release it unless you send us Bitcoin.
Initially, I thought it was my partner and I used our safe word, which is Rubber Chicken.
They still don't know it's not me.
Das hat er aber gut reingebastelt.
So now I'm like, oh shit, it's real.
Spoiler alert, it's not real.
You know, my first thought was like, well, can he like move the thing from his phone?
You know, if he can lock it and unlock it, I hope he can't like actually literally move
it to hurt me, but that's not how the device works.
So that was good, I guess.
Hang on, did Lorenzo just laugh at me?
Okay, das kann ich ihm jetzt gar nicht veröbeln, dass er darüber gelacht hat.
Ich mein, allein schon dieses Teil zu kaufen und zu...
Okay, was auch immer.
Wobei, letztendlich sollte der Typ, wenn er ihn zumindest so serious interviewt, nicht
lachen dabei.
Ja, das ist schon richtig.
Will er ihm jetzt erzählen, sie haben versucht, das Ding aufzuschneiden, oder was?
Okay.
Hat er sich jetzt noch sein Dick verletzt angeblich dabei, oder was?
That's the ticket price, that's where it's at, come see me live!
That's the best advertising I could have asked for.
So the interview is over, we've snuck in the plugs.
The only thing to do now is wait and see if Vice does any research and manages to catch me.
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Gut, zumal wir ja schon wissen, dass der Artikel veröffentlicht wurde.
This is Vice, they don't do research, they publish the story the next day.
So I gathered the Luke and Lewis podcast team to celebrate and read my work.
Currently have a headline from Vice.
I'm on Vice magazine, I've tricked them into writing a fake story about me.
About something that I thought they would be interested in.
And the headline is, we spoke to a guy who got his dick locked in a cage by a hacker.
A victim shares the scary story of when a hacker took control of his internet-connected chastity cage.
Sam Summers was sitting at home with his penis wrapped in his internet-connected chastity cage.
When he got a weird message on an app that connects to his device,
someone told him they had taken control and they wanted around $1,000 in Bitcoin to give control back to Summers.
So right away you can see, this is great promo for my festival show.
And also all 100% true. So far he has not lied to the press.
No, absolutely not.
Which is what you get up to on a Sunday.
This is from Sam. Initially I thought it was my partner doing that.
From Sam.
It sucks that there was a guy called Sam Summers out there going, Jesus.
This is not good for us.
I should have said my name was Luke Kijler.
Summers told Motherboard in a phone call, it sounds silly, but I got a bit excited by it.
Moment, warum hat...
Warum hat Summers angeblich der anderen Seite was erzählt?
Der hat doch direkt mit dem Typ telefoniert.
Macht es es irgendwie mehr credible oder wie heißt das?
Mehr glaubwürdig oder was, wenn es eine andere Seite ist?
Oder gehört das, oder gehört das dazu?
Ich lese das nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ah, die gehören dazu.
Das stimmt. Ich hab das auch gepostet.
Ich hab das auch retweeted.
Damals, vor zwei Monaten oder so.
Also das Ding hat wirklich Security-Probleme.
Das hab ich aber schon gesehen vor, frag mich nicht, vor letztes Jahr irgendwie auf Hacker News.
Gab's Leute, die haben rausgefunden, das Ding ist wirklich nicht sonderlich secure.
Warum hat er zwischendurch eigentlich immer so ultraschlechte Soundqualität?
Oh man, den kannst du aber wahrscheinlich echt alles unterjubeln.
Also ich lese das nicht, ich bin sicherlich bestimmt schon mal über den einen oder anderen
Weißartikel oder so stolpert, ja.
Aber das ist eine Seite, die lese ich nicht aktiv, das ist mir auch meistens zu durf.
Lass uns sowas auch mal machen, wobei der Bild oder was, das könnte man echt probieren.
Da bräuchte man aber was richtig Dummes.
Sowas, was jetzt nicht, ich guck dafür zu wenig in diese Seiten rein.
Um zu wissen, was die so drucken oder beziehungsweise drucken, was die so schreiben.
Aber das ist eine Story, die hätte bestimmt die Bild auch genommen.
Kann man sich irgendwann wieder, das ist eine äußerst exzellente Frage und die Antwort
ist nein, du kannst dir nie wieder eine neue Grafikkarte kaufen.
Du musst jetzt bis zum Ende deines Lebens mit der aktuellen Grafikkarte leben.
Du hast quasi deine Grafikkarte geheiratet, wenn du es so willst, nie wieder.
Real Talk, ich sag euch, wie es ist.
So, also was gucken wir uns jetzt an, 2, do it yourself Open Source Smart Home mit einem
Raspberry Pi, hätten wir zu bieten, ein Clickbait, Gbait, Level Cap Video, ich wette mit euch,
der erzählt wieder 20 Sekunden was zu Battlefield 6, dass man nichts weiß und, lul wer es glaubt
und dann ist vorbei.
Dann hätten wir noch was, die GameStar, die sich hoffentlich lustig macht über Stadia.
AliExpress ist kaputt, wie, die China-Chinesen-Seite ist weg, Moment, Moment, Moment, ich muss
mal kurz, ich muss kurz meine VM starten für AliExpress, Sekunde, das muss ich jetzt überprüfen
ob AliExpress, ist AliExpress wirklich kaputt, AliExpress an sich geht noch, ok, du suchst
was und er findet nix, schauen wir mal, AliExpress von uns, alles gut, extra VM für Ali, nein,
ne extra Linux VM für alles mögliche, aber ja, da mach ich auch AliExpress auf, bei dir
nicht, komisch, komisch, was haben wir sonst noch, äh, der Hour, irgendwas mit, was zum,
was hab ich denn da aufgemacht, 1999, da war gerade der N46 frisch, fast frisch seit
einem Jahr oder so, oder seit eineinhalb Jahren, wie Uploadfilter ab Juni das Internet für
immer verändern, ok, exzellent, exzellent, wir gucken jetzt, wir gucken jetzt das über
Stadia, da kann ich mich auch wieder ein bisschen lustig machen über Stadia, ihr wisst ja
negative Latency und so, ne, ja, ja, Stadia, alter, wir brauchen, wir brauchen eigentlich
noch, Moment, wir brauchen eigentlich noch das Stadia Logo, dass ich da drauf cac W'en
kann, Moment, das, das brauchen wir noch, wir haben schon ein paar andere Sachen, haben
wir ein transparentes Stadia Logo irgendwo, transparent, nicht transparent, doch, transparent,
aber ein SVG, ein SVG, hm, ich glaube, ich glaube mein, mein, Overlay, das kann kein
SVG, ich glaub, das hab ich da nicht eingebaut, das ist SVG, gibt's das nicht auch als PNG
irgendwo, Punkt Wine, what, ah ja, exzellent, Stadia, jetzt kopieren wir da jetzt rein,
mit Schriftzug, stimmt, sonst wissen die Leute nicht, was es ist, ist das ein PNG, ja, Stadia,
jetzt, zack, Stadia, Upload, gut, und jetzt kann ich folgendes machen, wenn's mal wieder
passt, okay, gucken wir uns das ganze an, gucken wir uns mal das, das WIT an.
Was falsch bei Stadia Games hätte die Schließung verhindert werden können und wie sieht die
Situation bei Mitbewerbern wie Amazon und deren Spielschmiede aus?
Bevor ich in das Warum gehe, noch ein ganz kurzer Abriss des wer, wo und wann, sehr kurz
deswegen, weil Google Stadia als Dienst erst seit November 2019 erhältlich ist.
Damals wurde es als cloud-basierte Gaming-Plattform vorgestellt, mit der auch hardwarehungerige
Spiele auf schwächeren Rechnern oder sogar Smartphones problemlos gespielt werden sollen.
Und nicht nur das, neben Entwicklern die Spiele exklusiv oder zeit-exklusiv für die Plattform
herausbringen, gab es mit Stadia Games in Entertainment auch noch ein internes Studio
für Spiele von Stadia, okay, man wundert sich ja tatsächlich jetzt, warum, neben Entwicklern
die Spiele exklusiv oder zeit-exklusiv für die Plattform herausbringen, gab es mit Stadia
Games in Entertainment auch noch, man wundert sich ja, warum Leute sowas nicht spielen
wollen, sieht das nicht nach einem absolut geilen Exklusivtitel für Stadia aus?
Also, wenn man das nicht spielen will, dann weiß ich ja auch nicht, äh, sieht das sich
doch voll next-gen und kompletter hier Kassenschlager so aus.
Ich kenne hier noch das Just Dance Video vom Friseur, beste.
Aber es gibt mittlerweile tatsächlich halbwegs brauchbare Stadia-Exklusiv-Spiele, also wie
viel denn, drei Stück, oder?
Was hier doch bei den aufgezählten Spielen auffällt, die sind alle nicht von Stadia.
Assassin's Creed Odyssey läuft auf Stadia, gilt es exklusiv für Stadia, aber von Stadia
Games in Entertainment gibt es zum Start erstmal nichts.
Was logisch ist, schließlich wurde das Studio erst im März 2019 angekündigt, zusammen
mit der Erinnerung von Jade Raymond, einer der Entwicklerinnen von Assassin's Creed,
als Head of Stadia Games in Entertainment.
Was passierte also in fast genau zwei Jahren zwischen Jade Raymond's Einstieg und Abschied?
Auf Seiten Stadias erstmal Missverständnisse und ein holpriger Start, so wurde der Dienst
im März 2019 noch als Netflix für Gamer beschrieben.
Dann kam raus, dass für die Spiele und das Streaming gezahlt werden musste.
Dann lief die Technik nicht sauber, Stadia fühlte sich zuviel eher nach Beta-Technik.
Und dann haben sie am Anfang diese komische Kombination gehabt aus, du brauchst diesen
Google, du brauchst den Chromecast Pro und für einen Controller, Moment, musstest du
sowas machen.
Das ist mal ernsthaft, das ist eines der unästhetischsten Kombinationen aus Handy und Controller,
die ich je gesehen habe, guck dich das an.
Das ist so schlecht, das ist so schlecht, ich weiß auch nicht, wie man es viel hätte anders
machen können.
Das erste ist schon mal bei Bluetooth den Controller und nicht mit so einem komischen
Kabel.
Das sieht so beschissen aus mit dem Smartphone auf diesem komischen 3D gedruckt oder sieht
ein bisschen aus, wie als hätte ich mir daheim 3D gedruckten Clip her, ich finde das sieht
so für den Arsch aus, oh nein, ach ja und am Anfang ging es im Browser nicht, was kann
man eigentlich mit so einem Chromecast, wenn man einen hat, jetzt noch machen, bringt der
überhaupt noch was?
Oh doch so viel.
Und das Abschalten, das hat sich ja gelohnt.
Wahrscheinlich war das komplettes Management Disaster, die haben das Ding aufgemacht und
keiner wusste eigentlich, was Sache ist, agil aussehen, by the way, wenn ich das schon
wieder sehe, wer soll eigentlich konzentriert arbeiten können in so einer Atmosphäre, das
sieht zwar immer super agil und hip aus, aber niemand kann so konzentriert arbeiten.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die auf die Idee kommen, dass Großraumbüros oder noch noch schlimmer
so Openwork gedöhnt sind, dass das überhaupt ordentlich funktioniert.
Diese Frau, dieser Mann, dieser Hund und warum verraten sie mir nicht wenigstens ein bisschen
davon?
Das Studio wird geschlossen, ohne dass ich je herausgefunden habe, welche Spiele mir
jetzt durch die Lappen gehen, natürlich ist es besser nichts zu zeigen, wenn man nichts
hat, als Trailer von Dingen, die am Ende gar nicht ins Spiel kommen, aber nachdem das Studio
so groß angekündigt wurde, war ich dann doch neugierig, was dort in Arbeit ist, vielleicht
wenigstens ein Genre.
Am 1.
Februar teilt Vizepräsident und General-Linager von Google Stadia für alle, wo ich gerade
Cyberpunk sehe.
Kann mir jemand erklären, was der Sinn von dem Charakter-Editor in Cyberpunk überhaupt
ist, wenn du deinen Charakter quasi nie siehst?
Ich hab das nicht gespielt bis jetzt.
Und Stadia Games in Entertainment geschlossen wird.
Es soll mehr darum gehen, Entwicklern zu helfen, ihre Spiele für Stadia zu optimieren, anstatt
selbst welche zu entwickeln.
Spiele von Anfang bis Ende zu entwickeln, die zu den Besten ihrer Hilfe gehören, sagt
er, braucht mehrere Jahre und signifikantes Investment, verbunden mit exponentiell steigenden
Kosten.
Oder kurz gesagt, selbst...
Hey, das ist der Negative-Latency-Typ.
Das ist der, der auch erzählt hat, Stadia hat Negative-Latency.
Zu viel Mühe und kostet zu viel Geld.
Das sollen lieber andere machen.
Stattdessen wollte man lieber die zugrunde liegende Cloud-Streaming-Technik stärken
und ausbauen, damit die Spiele, die von anderen Developern für Stadia erscheinen, stabil
laufen.
Damit verlieren 150 Mitarbeiter ihren Job, unter anderem Assassin's Creed-Entwicklerin
Jade Raymond, das Unternehmen nach dem Bekanntwerden der Nachrichten komplett verließt.
Na gut, die findet sicherlich auch was anderes.
Google hat sich verpflichtet, mit den Betroffenen zusammenzuarbeiten und neue Positionen zu
finden.
Aber eins ist klar.
Stadia Games in Entertainment...
Das ist einfach nur Marketing-Gelaber, die machen das zu und die Entwickler sind auf
einen Schlag arbeitslos.
Die sagen, wir versuchen, den Übergang möglichst weich zu gestalten, wir suchen andere Positionen.
Ja, vielleicht für 5 Stück mag das sein, die woanders noch gut sind, der Rest ist einfach
instant arbeitslos.
Was ist eigentlich aus Far Cry 6 geworden, das kommt irgendwann demnächst in etwas längerer
Zeitspanne.
Da siehst du mal, du kannst auf Stonksmann-Aussagen halt abschneiden, aber das ist nicht so.
Stonksmann-Aussagen halt absolut nichts geben, da wird einfach nur irgendwas gesagt, ohne
dass es irgendwie eine Base für gibt, da muss doch nicht mal eine Funken Wahrheit dran sein,
da wird einfach gesagt.
Eine Woche!
Deswegen hat die Schließung so viele Beobachter und auch die Mitarbeiter so überrascht.
Warum etwas schließen, was gut läuft?
Glauben wir Google selbst, ist es der schnöde Mammon.
Wie im Statement von Phil Harrison erwähnt, AAA-Erfolgstitel dauern zu lange und sind
zu teuer.
Sie haben es probiert.
Nein, damit hätte ja so jemand wie Google nicht rechnen können und ich bin mir auch
ziemlich sicher, Google fehlt es sicherlich am Geld.
Also wir wissen ja alle, dass Google kein Geld hat.
Der viel ausprobiert und viel Geld in neue Ideen steckt.
Manche Dinge funktionieren gut, manche nicht.
Google Mail oder Google Maps waren super Ideen, Google Plus nicht so, aber genauso wenig wie
Google sich scheut Dinge auszuprobieren, haben sie auch kein Problem damit erfolglose Projekte
schnell wieder salopp gesagt in die Tolle zu kloppen.
Das stimmt und erfolglos ist bei Google so ein Ding, das heißt nicht, dass es keiner
benutzt hat oder das können auch viele genutzt haben und es ist erfolglos aus Google Sicht.
Für mich ist ja einer persönlich einer der größten Google Fails, klar ich mein objektiv
gesehen sowas wie Google Plus, aber für mich ist enttäuschungsmäßig und einer der größten
Fails für mich immer noch Google, wie hieß das Lens, nein, wie hieß das Ding, doch Lens
oder?
Wie hieß diese Augmented Reality Brille nochmal, nicht Glasses, nicht Lens, Glass, nicht Holo
Lens, nein, nein Glasses, Google Glasses meine ich, genau, das war für mich so eines der
größten Enttäuschungen und Fails, die sie da fabriziert haben.
Ich glaube von Glasses ist eigentlich nie großartig was hängen geblieben bei den Leuten
im Kopf außer, dass der Google Chef mit der Glasses Chefentwicklerin fremd gegangen ist.
So ein Scheiß merkt man sich, sowas merkt man sich, ne, aber Glasses war komplett der
Einfall, ne, Google hat einfach mal planlos irgendwas gemacht, das kann Google gut.
Epic Games ist ja spätestens seit Unreal ging ja total ab mit ihrer Engine-Lizenzierung,
mal ganz ehrlich, so richtig groß ging Epic Games mal richtig durch die Decke mit und
an Fortnite.
Was ich jetzt auch, was ich in diesem Werbefilm immer witzig finde, guckt euch das mal an,
ihr denkt da arbeiten 90% Frauen, was wahrscheinlich eher genau umgedreht ist.
Ja natürlich, die wollen ja Geld verdienen, ehm, wisst ihr was ich bei diesen, was ich
jetzt hier habe, ich hab jetzt Assassin's Creed nicht gespielt, aber das ist ne Sache,
die triggert mich bei allen möglichen Games wo es Nahkampf gibt, guckt mal, die haben
die übelste Rüstung an, okay die haben naggische Ärme, vielleicht hatte man das so, die haben
die übelste Rüstung an, die schlagen sich, guckt mal, die schlagen sich permanent, die
schlagen sich auf die Rüstung und es spritzt Blut, warum spritzt Blut, wofür hat der Typ
überhaupt ne Metallrüstung an, wenn es doch einfach durchgeht.
Guckt euch das an, der hat eben auf den Rücken gehauen, das ist einfach ne Metallrüstung,
also das wird denen in Wirklichkeit absolut null jucken.
Äh, ja, das ist exzellent, Massive Triple A, okay, aber Amazon Games hat auch viel in
den, die haben eigentlich mehr oder weniger alles in den Sand gesetzt, jetzt irgendwann
demnächst kommt New World, ich bin mal gespannt, ob die MMO technisch irgendwas hinkriegen,
es sind ja viele Leute von den Betas massiv begeistert gewesen, mal gucken, also ich werde
mir das bestimmt mal kurz angucken, so als alter MMO Grinder, ob das jetzt so ne riesen
Ding wird, ich bin ja da noch skeptisch, ne.
Ey, Leute, es gibt noch ne andere Option, außer dass die Leute nackt sind, es gibt
auch noch die Option, dass einfach Treffer an der Rüstung nicht, nicht Blut spritzen,
das wäre auch ne Möglichkeit, oder, die können ja meinetwegen sogar n bisschen Damage machen,
ist ja okay, könnte man sagen, ja okay, da hat er drauf geschlagen, was auch immer, aber
es sollte vielleicht kein Blut spritzen, wenn an der Stelle ganz klar, äh, Metallrüstung
ist.
Ja, das wird bald released, irgendwann im August, ne, ich glaube den wird gar nicht
so viel übrig bleiben.
By the way, ich bin immer noch ein oldschool MMO Mensch, ich finde zu viel Instancing nicht
gut, weil dann die Spielwelt einfach leer ist, beziehungsweise, ähm, du random Matchmaker
hast über zig Server und du die Leute nach der Instance dann nie wieder siehst und sowas,
das finde ich nicht das, was für mich MMOs ausmacht, klar, man kann manche, manche, manchen
Content schon instanzieren, gerade wenn das nur wenig gibt und 5 Player Content ist, dass
quasi, äh, der halbe Server das spielen will und es geht nur einer, das kann ich schon
verstehen, aber, ähm, so wie das teilweise gemacht, das sind aktuell MMOs mit, mit, äh,
Cross Server, Dungeon Finder und quasi, mehr oder weniger alles instanziert und on the
fly instanziert und riesen Server, quasi, 5000 Leute zusammen und nie siehst du die
gleiche Person zweimal, finde ich nicht sinnig, was MMOs angeht, das ist was, was mir ehrlich
gesagt nicht zusagt bei MMOs.
Nix, nix, nix, ich hätte KW nicht gespielt, wenn Stadia exklusiv ist.
Moment, gab es nicht Skyrim schon für Alexa?
Ich weiß, das war ein Witz, aber, also damals, aber die Idee fand ich witzig, ja, also ich
hab so nie verstanden, warum man sich für Stadia als Plattform entscheidet, aber gut.
Und ich sag euch, die werden auch nie so beliebt, aber man WashingtonTINA nicht, aufgrund
das viele dazu bringen könnte den service für einen probemundant auszuprobieren und ihn dann vielleicht so zu mögen dass man ihn weiter nutzt
ohne diese spiele ist stadia zumindest aktuell einfach nur noch ein weiterer streaming dienst ja und die sind aktuell einfach noch nicht
So beliebt wie google vielleicht dachte und ich sage euch die werden auch nie so beliebt
das ist so ein ding das für ein paar leute
Heute ist das vielleicht ansprechendes system aber es gibt bestimmt welche die sagen
Hey, ich will mobil die kaufen sich lieber eine switch wenn sie wirklich mobil spielen wollen und alle anderen
Und gerade pc gaming fans die haben fette pc daheim stehen und spielen pc spiele halt am pc
Eventuell auch mit controller aber halt am pc
Der glaube dass streaming alles verändern wird basierter auf der sicht dass es eine menge leute gibt die ein echtes interesse an interaktivem
entertainment ja aber lasst aber wenn die grafikkarte kaputt geht und man keine neue kauft das ist jetzt eine temporäre geschichte das ist jetzt kein kein
verkaufs modell für stadia wo man wo man drauf bauen kann
wobei weiß man
Ich bin mir nicht sicher dass das wirklich so eingetroffen ist
Vielleicht oder sehr wahrscheinlich ist google seinerzeit voraus und wird in ein paar jahren mit einer stabilen und gut ausgebauten streaming plattform glänzen
wenn wir dann hier mal gut ausgebautes breitband internet hätten ja
Moment moment moment
bis
2018 haben wir schon alle 50 mbit das kann nicht sein
So was ist wenigstens cooles spannende spiele herauszubringen die uns neugierig auf ihren service machen
gerade weil google mit seiner idee vom spiele streaming ja nicht alleine ist oder reicht es dafür sowie aktuell gemacht einfach
Exklusivität von anderen developpern einzukaufen immerhin ist google eins der erfolgreichsten unternehmen der welt sie machen also aus wirtschaftlicher sicht sehr viel richtig
Hier interessiert mich eure meinung falls ihr bis jetzt nicht an stadia interessiert seid ich bin null
null an stadia interessiert
weil mein maus sharing ist abgekackt
Ich kann meine maus nicht mal bewegen auf den zweiten bildschirm moment
Sieh los ich bin gespannt warum warum geht das nicht
Es ist abgekackt sack
Hey, was ist hier los
Mein maus sharing ist abgekackt sekunde exit
Ich brauche zugriff auf mein zweiter monitor das ordentliche
Overlay geht und jetzt geht es wieder exzellent exzellent
Funktioniert wieder sehr gut
Übrigens chat das ist eine gute frage und zwar
Laufen nicht alle spiele auf linux weil die lizenzkosten will man nicht abdrücken ich weiß nicht ob es linux oder bsd ist ich glaube es ist linux
In stadia die playstation ist ist in den net bsd free bsd körner oder sowas aber ich glaube gar nicht mal so sehr dass es
an den lizenzkosten liegt
die man nicht ab ab drücken will an ms ich glaube eher das liegt daran dass linux im serverbereich und
Fähigkeiten was was was ich cluster angeht und verteilung automatisierung deploy und sowas weil das einfach um
20 billionen prozent angenehmer ist als windows
Ich glaube der hauptsächlich die grund ist dass man einfach so eine linux infrastruktur viel viel einfacher betreiben kann als irgendwie in riesen
Rechner haufen aus windows dinger die ich glaube die lizenzkosten sind sogar gar nicht so sehr das problem
Das kann sein es wäre ja nicht so
unrealistisch
Das zu machen wenn das wenn das google ist ja kann schon sein keine ahnung
Die treiber problemen unter linux gibt es aber in dem fall nicht weil das feste hardware ist
Und man sich darauf ist ein bisschen wie konsolen hardware wie gesagt die playstation läuft auch unter bsd und da funktioniert das auch
Ja, also das ist kein das ist kein ding das ist das ist nur ein problem so im für euch auf dem desktop ist es ein
Problem für google ist das kein problem für play für die playstation ist auch kein problem
Welches tool verwendest du für die maus das da maus without borders
Windows only leider man kann auch synergy verwenden das heißt ja nicht mehr synergy wie heißt das jetzt
Ist auch so ein ding so ein maus sharing programm das geht dann unter mac linux und windows aber in dem fall habe ich ja nur
Windows auf beiden rechnern und mein linux desktop habe ich hier auf dem auf dem anderen
Zum umschalten da brauche ich das mit der maus nicht
Häuse ohne grenzen
Genau so jetzt haben wir das schon geguckt was gucken wir uns als nächstes als nächstes gucken wir uns das smart home mit dem raspberry pi an
Leute ich bin ja immer noch am überlegen ob ich nicht eine
Ne smart home tour bei mir mache die scheiße ich habe kein bock irgendwas zu liegen weil irgendwas über sehe ich bestimmt da steht dann irgendwo drin
Standort mit gps koordinaten oder sowas wenn ich nicht aufpasse
Das ist dann wo bleek
Oder das will ich nicht
Dann macht ein video ja meine ich ja ich über sehe da garantiert irgendwas
Okay also open source smart home mit was hat er geschrieben wie viel 300 300 euro
Moment
Bei der way wenn ihr die samt mel zu einem video sehen wollt macht das video einfach in firefox auf und wenn ihr das video in firefox
Auf macht dann seht ihr das samt mel bevor es anfängt zu spielen excellent
Oder auch nicht normalerweise schon
Ja da ist es doch
Tut yourselves smart home
Da steht nichts von 300 euro
Ich will klingeln mit camera no dreads home assistant ja so will ich das auch machen
Exzellente auseinander gebaute smart steckdosen das aber guck mal hier der stromzähler lull das kommt mir doch irgendwie bekannt vor mit dem stromzähler
euch nicht auch
Wo wir gerade beim thema stromzähler auslesen sind da habe ich letztens auch was gebastelt
Hat hat gewisse ähnlichkeiten dazu nur dass ich sagen muss ich finde meins sieht schöner aus
Dadurch dass ich hier extra so fair versliefte usb kabel genommen habe um
Das zu verlängern und den deckel hab für jeden sensor
Okay gucken wir uns das gucken wir uns das mal an
2016 hat mark zuckerberg
Zuckerberg ja
Der zuck der zuck aller schellen versucht sein haus intelligent zu machen und damals war ich wirklich gespannt auf die ergebnisse
Aber selbst vier jahre später ist nichts davon der zuck oder anders nützlich veröffentlicht
Ja gut facebook würde sogar also also facebook
Diese facebook
Alexa diese facebook alexa klone oder dieses dies wie hieß denn das da dieses die haben ja auch mal versucht so was richtung alexa und smart home zu
Machen das ist nicht gut angekommen weil das genau zu dieser zeit war wo
Die diese ganze facebook spioniert geschichte war das ist kein wunder dass der kram mich das nicht gekauft hat ja
Ne captain peng habe ich nicht das war lightning kabel ich habe mich versprochen ich habe miss erzählt ist gar kein usb
Das sind lightning kabel mal gewesen das ein ein irgendwie fünf meter lightning kabel habe ich und das habe ich nicht mehr gebraucht habe ich
Jetzt einfach mache ich jetzt bis es alles einfach sensorverlängerung skabel draus passt nämlich genau weil lightning hat
plusminus und zwei datenleitungen
Mark zuckerberg hat javis als namen für eine hauskari ziemlich uncool gemacht
Und
Alter warum hat er warum hat er so dumme furzgeräusche trille
Grinch grinch selber machen angesagt ich habe mich gefragt was man innerhalb eines jahres mit einem budg von nur
300 euro statt ein paar milliarden von facebook so viel viel
Und das nach möglichkeit nur mit open source viel ohne kompromisse jetzt kommt das ergebnis
Innerhalb von einem jahr kannst du unglaublich viel machen ich war muss ich mal überlegen
Wenn du bei aliexpress für du kriegst da bei aliexpress für 20 euro schon
Fünf controller mit sensoren
Das intro was gleich kommt ist hardcore grinch euch dachte das war schon hardcore grinch
Was
Na gut
Wenn mich tatsächlich mal jemand besucht dann klingelt er für gewöhnlich was hat er okay okay das muss ich mir mal angucken was er da
was er da am start hat
Warum mache ich das video da zu klein wenn ich mir angucken will sp 32 cam modul
Ja die kammer verwenden ich bin kein persönlich kein allzu großer fan von dem von der sp 32 cam
Und lcd display kann man machen ist eine ganz gute ganz gute geschichte sieht man schon der graben ist auch nicht sonderlich teuer
Aber ich mag das sp 32 modul ehrlich gesagt nicht sonderlich das ist ich habe mir mal eins bestellt
Aber auch schon wieder ein halbes jahr oder so her ein bisschen mit rumgebastelt es gibt es gibt fertige sketches dafür hat man auch ein schönes
control interface
das ding kann ja angeblich bis fahrt mich
85 fps oder so angeblich total viel aber es sieht also meiner meinung nach es sieht nicht gut aus und es ist auch ganz schön laggy
also da ist
eine kamera mit einem raspberry pi 0 tatsächlich besser und das problem was diese ganzen
Was übrigens auch der raspberry hat mit diesen kameras die haben alle nicht so easy die möglichkeit
nachts sicht zu machen weil
damit man quasi auch im dunklen was sehen kann gibt es zwei varianten entweder man macht einfach licht hin dass es das hell macht
oder man macht irgendwie noch ansteuerbare infrarot leds dann braucht man aber auch eine kamera die mit infrarot licht zurechtkommt
und am besten dann tagsüber noch die möglichkeit einen infrarot filter einzuschalten weil wenn du eine kamera hast die
dass das
quasi quasi alles aufnimmt dann ist jetzt tagsüber kacke aus also ja es ist nicht so einfach
Deswegen bin ich da kein großer fan von und habe immer noch und habe immer noch
überall normale kameras so billige billige
fertig kameras wurde rtsp streamen kannst und die einzige raspberry pi kamera die ich hab die
ist für die haustür tatsächlich auch
und die habe ich so eingestellt
dass die tagsüber läuft die mit 15 fps das ist dann relativ flüssig aber nachts geht es runter auf
2,5 fps das ist das kleines was man einstellen kann 2,5 fps legt da die
dann hat man eine höhere belichtungszeit für jedes einzelne bild und dementsprechend reicht das licht von der laterne auf der straße
dass man gute bilder mit der kamera bekommt mit 2,5 fps oder was das gute bilder man erkennt eigentlich mehr oder weniger alles
dann klingelt bei mir das telefon und ich bekomme ein bilder's handy das habe ich oder eine nacht das habe ich tatsächlich auch so was ähnliches
und das habe ich auch im esp 32 gemacht allerdings mein esp 32
ist in der wand an der gegensprechanlage
reingestöpselt und erkennt anhand der der spannung die dort drauf ist ob es gerade geklingelt hat oder nicht
der hersteller hat nämlich irgendwie so was gebraucht ganz merkwürdig das system
ruhe spannung 15 volt es klingelt 26 volt und
es ist so ein kleines bild
es klingelt 26 volt und es ist es läuft ein gespräch 20 volt
warum auch immer weil
und das lese ich einfach mit einem
analog digital konverter quasi ein und und dann geht's ja
ja
hey siri haustür öffnen
moment das ist das ist vielleicht ein bisschen ein bisschen monka security wenn ich einfach sagen kann hey siri haustür öffnen
oder alexa funktioniert natürlich wirklich warum ich siri aber nicht mag darauf komme ich gleich noch
by the way das ist eine coole konstruktion
aber je nachdem wie er die stromversorgung gemacht hat falls das mit einer batterie geht ich hoffe mal nicht
falls das mit einer batterie geht dann hält das nicht lang ach jedoch akku akku hält mindestens sechs monate
akku hält mindestens sechs monate ja kann schon sein es ist ein
d1 mini esp8 66 dann irgendwie ein paar custom boards ein motor eine motorsteuerung und
ja da noch mal den controller drauf das ist noch mal eine antenne
was ist das vielleicht ist es ein normales funktmodul was man braucht für was auch immer
ach das ist nein das ist kein bluetooth ach stimmt doch das muss bluetooth sein weil das sind 2866
der hat glaube ich zumindest ja der hat nur eine reihe pins der hat gar keinen bluetooth standardmäßig
das dann muss das da unten wirklich bluetooth sein ja das ist der mot die motorsteuerung
halbes jahr ist ganz schön optimistisch selbst im deep sleep für das ding
darauf komme ich gleich noch
beim entwickeln und programmieren kommen die schwierigkeiten meist da wo man sie am wenigsten
erwartet zum beispiel hat die lichtsteuerung die die weichen übergänge erzeugt die datenübertragung
gestört da darf man nicht zu schnell aufgeben als belohnung informiert mich jetzt auch mein
briefkasten über neue post sowas ich steuermittel so was will ich auch noch bauen leider haben wir
so einen komischen custom briefkasten den der opa mal gebaut hat da ist das nicht so einfach da
so schalter rein zu bekommen beziehungsweise schaltet noch ordentlich funktionieren auf die
idee oft da auf die idee bin ich auch schon gekommen habe ich auch noch nicht umgesetzt
post ich steuere mittlerweile eigentlich alles über das noten dashboard da kann ich sehen ob
die garage offen oder zu ist das kann ich hier über den sensor abrufen oder wie weit mein auto
von der werkbank entfernt steht das ist eine coole steuerung registriert wenn ich nicht da
bin so kann ich über 433 megahertz fenster kontakte eine mitteilung da habe ich keine
433 megahertz fenster kontakte ich habe sieben fenster kontakte was keine ahnung auf welcher
frequenz ist könnte das nicht auf 433 sein ich weiß nicht auf 433 diese klassische klassische
f funk schichte das ist übrigens eine coole idee mit der waschmaschine das habe ich mir
auch schon überlegt und so erkennen kann wann die waschmaschine fertig ist aber mir ist was
viel einfacheres eingefallen man macht einfach eine steckdose an die waschmaschine die messen
kann wie viel strom verbraucht wird und also also wie viel leistung das ding braucht und daran
erkennt man auch easy ob die fertig ist weil wenn das unter sagen wir unter 50 watt fällt für
über fünf minuten dann ist das ding fertig das ist ich dachte auch erst so was danach habe ich
mir gedacht man könnte den rüttel sensor machen rüttel sensor kannst du auch der erkennt dann
wenn das ding wackelt und oder weißt okay schleudert das ist in 15 minuten fertig oder so aber die
einfachste variante ist oftmals tatsächlich bei so heim automatisierungssache die beste weil auch
die fehler unanfälligste und ich bin zu dem schutz gekommen die beste variante für die waschmaschine
ist eine steckdose die messen kann was das ding an leistung braucht leicht angepasst bekomme
ich damit auch mit wann die alte waschmaschine fertig ist als empfänger dafür dient ein
umfunktionierter dvbt stick der empfängt alle verschlüsselten wetterstationen so weiter ich
habe mir das kamer im dvbt stick machen ich habe mir mal einen eigenen einen eigenen rf empfänger
gekauft vor einer weile weil ich meine fenster rollos ich habe bei ungefähr der hälfte der
fenster habe ich automatisierte rollos die kam von von somfie heißt das glaube ich die die waren in
dem haus dann also die wurden schon eingebaut bevor ich 2013 bevor ich ein haum automation gedacht
habe und das ist noch rf glaube auch rf 433 und da habe ich mir eine station gekauft die dieses
funk protokoll was die quasi über über 433 megahertz machen das ist kein normales was man
irgendwie mitschneiden kann und dann geht's was das kann und damit kann ich jetzt auch meine
rolladen dinger steuern bis den keppenpeng sensoren und einen regensensor besorgt wer will kann sich
auch noch einen luftqualitätssensor haben ich mir auch schon überlegt ob ich das machen soll
aber die sache ist die ich sehe den sinn von mich gibt gibt coole projekte aber gibt auch viele
projekte wo ich mich frage ok wo ist der sinn davon dass das habe ich mir auch kurz überlegt
habe ich mir okay aber bad war bad war mir fällt übrigens ein von diesen verteilerdosen brauche
ich noch ein paar zack die sind alle mittlerweile gut dass wir das video geguckt haben ja moment
90 sommer billig warum kostet es nur 90 cent cool
IP 54 das reicht mir erst einmal
ach die kammer nicht zuschrauben die kammer nur stecken oder was ja aber das trotzdem übelst
billig moment
ich werde mich werde mal kurz wo ich nein ich habe mein handy nicht hier für amazon bestellung
werde ich nach dem stream werde ich eine runde ordern kann ich mal ein fünfer pack bestellen
90 cent alle auf den juck davon brauche ich auf jeden fall wieder welche so gucken wir
erst mal weiter die kostet im fachhandel nur 40 cent sagst du oder weißt du
die sind noch recht teuer korrekt abgespeichert kann man die daten hervorragend in graf hana
wo wir gerade beim thema sind leute leute graf hana habe ich euch in letzter zeit schon mal
mein heizungs dashboard gezeigt das ist auch nice glaube das habe ich euch noch nie gezeigt
der heiz jam da sieht man zum beispiel dass heute nacht hat die heizung nicht geheizt was ja auch
sinnvoll ist was war wahrscheinlich warm genug ja und und im kessel ja der hat doch der hat der
hat heute nacht einfach den kessel nicht weiter geheizt und hat die verbleibende sache im kessel
dazu benutzt zu heizen soweit es nötig war genau guckt auch hier abgastemperatur hat einfach
heute nacht nicht weiter weiter aufgeheizt hier gepumpt gepumpt wurde es war anscheinend warm
genug gepumpt hatte auch kaum exzellent exzellent so gucken wir mal weiter wann kommt das strom
der sport das habe ich schon aber ich habe angst dass ich da was liege wenn ich euch mal
haue was ist denn zeig achso und der dvb t stick hängt an einem raspberry pi mini computer das
ist mein zentralrechner auf dem wirklich alles läuft ok selbst wenn da kein internet da ist
während man sich bei der konkurrenz für weit über 500 ja das stimmt das hat er nicht unrecht die
ganzen profi smart home zentralen die sacken zum größten teil also ok das muss ich das kann man
so nicht sagen wenn man sich auf eine technik festlegt und damit alles machen will und halt
wirklich sich um nicht selbst kümmern will dann kann man das machen aber das schöne ist wenn du
sowas wie home assistant verwendest du kannst halt alles miteinander integrieren ich meine ich habe
sachen über oldschool rf 433 funk ich habe sich b ich habe sie wave ich habe sachen über bluetooth
über die unterschiedlichsten protokolle wifi alles mögliche und das alles integriert in einem
in einer zentrale das können die dinger alle nicht und natürlich relativ relativ günstig im
vergleich zu so fertigstingern gut dafür muss man sich halt auch um viele selbst kümmern ja
v winnie wahrscheinlich wir wünschen winnie gaming dankeschön für den primes ab ja
und wie gesagt es muss kein raspberry pi sein ich habe es bei mir auch nicht auf
raspberry pi laufen sondern auf so einer low power intel plattform die einfach ein
bisschen mehr power hat als ein raspberry pi weil ich lasse noch mehr darüber laufen als nur
home smart home über 500 euro abzocken lassen kann und dafür lediglich ein smartes relay bekommt
kostet der raspberry pi nur knappe 40 euro und braucht nur etwa 5 watt das muss man sich mal
rein zwar jetzt wobei die leute die sich gerne abzocken lassen überzeugt hier sowieso nicht wenn
man den raspberry pi dann noch mit einer ssd festplatte für circa 30 euro erweitert läuft
darauf problemlos nextcloud einer open source alternative zu dropbox google drive oder iCloud
damit können von überall dateien kalender und kontakte synchronisiert werden ohne dass auch
nur ich mag keine nextcloud das das wisst ihr mittlerweile auch ich will nicht jedes mal wenn
einer was zu nextcloud nextcloud flamen aber ich mag nicht ich habe es auch und ich mag es nicht
zu hause es geht das sogar maximal schnell denn die daten müssen nicht erst durchs internet
geschickt werden mit pi hole bekommt man einen netzwerkweiten werbeblocker und eine kindersicherung
kann man machen ja auf geld aus youtube werbung sollte ich nicht unbedingt hoffen wenn ich
erkläre wie man sie blockiert man kann sie damit aber schlecht blockieren also gerade twitch und
youtube werbung gehen damit wirklich schlecht youtube geht wahrscheinlich halbwegs mit den
ordentlichen filterlisten aber twitch geht beispielsweise gar nicht aber natürlich will
ich auch nicht sagen ihr soll twitch werbung blocken weil dann bekomme ich ja weniger geld
also guckt guckt mal alles schön twitch werbung läuft auf meinem raspberry noch motion eye womit
ich zentral alle kameras steuern und über motion eye ich weiß ich muss bei allem laufen pause
machen aber ich habe den ganzen kram auch schon ausprobiert motion eye mag ich auch nicht motion
eye ist laggy as fuck und überfordert den raspberry pi total also es sei denn man steht
auf 45 fps in den kameras das ist der grund warum ich das selbst was gebastelt habe was über web
rtc geht und da kannst du auch zehn kameras mit 30 fps machen wohlgemerkt aber nur wenn
die kamera selbst rtsp mit einem im browser funktionierenden stream macht also quasi
264 encoded cofax sechs monat lang für den sub was würdest du was würdest du für einen
self-hosted ai assistenten erzählen habe ich noch nichts großartig ausprobiert die china
kamera jawoll beste empfehlung chinesen kamera china china chinesen chinesen kamera
by the way ich würde ich würde das das das das das eine dns blocken sowieso mag sein ich
würde für diese dinger immer einen extra wlan machen immer komplett mit mit mit client
isolation an dass die dinger nicht miteinander reden können und firewall technisch also
eigenes entweder eigenes subnetz komplett und es muss durch die firewall durch oder
noch ein eigenes wlan drunter falls man noch physische ports da irgendwie braucht dass
das voneinander getrennt ist also die dinger dürfen bei mir auch nirgends wohin das ist
ich habe ein eigenes china iot wlan wlan netz alles und das würde ich nie ins normale
wlan stellen aber schreibt er ja auch ja motion eyes sagt motion eyes fünf fps mit ein paar
kameras aber darauf nicht die privatsphäre also ich meine ja was du wahrscheinlich machen
kannst ist irgendein irgendein dual core dual core intel ding nehmen und da irgendwie
transcode oder so keine ahnung ob ich ausprobiert dann mag das vielleicht gut funktionieren
wenn man quasi das auf eine extra extra kiste packt aber verletzen oder gegen datenschutzgesetze
zu verstoßen über pi vpn verbinde ich mich schlussendlich von überall aus sicher und
verschlüsselt in mein heimnetz ja musikfans interessiert die beste variante man selbst
aus uralten radios für ein paar euro bluetooth lautsprecher machen kann zu einem guten smart
home ja natürlich auch smarte steckdosen die gibt es in den verschiedensten varianten
man sollte allerdings nicht davor zurückschrecken auch mal ein auseinander zu bauen und neue
firmen darauf zu flaschen ey ist das die die wir auch ausländer ne aber das ist auch so
eine gosund gosund steckdose aber wir haben ja im stream schon auch dinge auseinander
gebaut erinnert ihr euch noch dran wo ich fast verzweifelt bin das ding aufzukriegen
haben wir das noch in der historie drinne schon mal kurz gucken ich glaube das ist zu
lang her das haben wir nicht mehr in der historie drinne ne das ne moment aber wir haben doch
das archiv archiv oder das archiv wie die coolen leute das sagen das war das war 2021
die wurde mit den clips probleme hat es genau das genau das nicht 2021 2020 war das noch
top hier 12 ach du scheiße da habe ich aber viel gestreamt hier doch nicht ne das war
was anderes ja da bin ich am basteln das ist das ist die rgb leiste für weihnachten
gewesen nein war das war das denn tatsächlich schon im november hier rgb rgb hier da ist
er da habe ich dran rumgezerrt ich habe es nicht aufgekriegt ich habe es nicht aufgekriegt
irgendwann irgendwann verbiege ich auch noch dieses diesen zahnarzt spachtel da das geht
einfach nicht bei der wei wisst ihr was ich falsch gemacht habe aber wo sieht man das
ding von vorne max zeigt das ding noch mal von vorne hier in wirklichkeit das was ich
hier mache hier neben sind schrauben dran gewesen also man hätte den aufkleber abmachen
können oder mit dem schrauben schrauben jetzt hier durch stechen und die schrauben
raus machen können also nicht hier wo ich das rein stecke sondern daneben aber ich
habe ewig rum gemacht ich habe es nicht aufgekriegt ich habe dann irgendwann die harten geschütze
rausgeholt guckt euch das mal es ist total kaputt danach aber gleich krieg ichs auf ich
glaube gleich krieg ichs auf max gib alles gib alles oh nee volle pulle ich glaube aber
jetzt krieg ichs auf gleich welche esp firmware selbstgemachte oder tas motor gibt ja keine
wirklich gute alternative zu tas motor finde ich guck guck guck max auf auf gib alles
ah da habe ichs aufgekriegt oder jetzt jetzt jetzt auf ich glaube jetzt jetzt jetzt ich
glaube jetzt habe ich so was gesagt wie scheiß drauf ich im zweifelsfall mache ich einfach
kaputt und und und und
so moment ich habe ein tastatur halb runter geschmissen gerade
da ist eine schraube guck mal und jetzt habe ich fest jetzt habe ich festgestellt da vorne
ist die schraube guck mal
jetzt habe ich festgestellt vorne ist eine schraube naja gut aber ihr seht ich bin auch
am basteln was sowas angeht und danach haben wir das custom geflasht und gut ist das hat
dann aber tatsächlich sogar ganz gut funktioniert das custom flaschen ich weiß die meisten
leute würden wahrscheinlich im leben nicht eine steckdose custom flaschen und sie danach
noch verwenden aber es hat funktioniert ja jetzt wird geflasht lötschamp lötschamp
ok da habe ich sie schon geflasht und am ende habe ich auch noch geguckt guck am ende
habe ich geguckt funktioniert und man kann sogar remote schalten excellent excellent
genau und das was er hier hat ist auch so eine gosundt sieht man auch an der farbe steht
ja auch drauf hier guck gosundt by the way wie heißt gosundt nach corona gesundt huge
joke ich weiß auch mal ein auseinander zu bauen neue firmware drauf zu flaschen denn
sonst endet man mit tausenden apps auf dem handys alle nach china oder sonst wo telefonieren
wollen absolut zu empfehlen der alternativ firmware ist das motor ja da hat er recht
hier kann man das motor beste also weil irgendjemand gefragt hat was mein lieblingsfirma also
wie gesagt das motor ist meiner mein auch die einzig sinnvolle die es gibt es gibt
ein paar andere sachen sowas wie esp home und sowas das ist allerdings eher für leute
die was programmieren wollen oder die ein bisschen mehr selbst machen wollen und da
bin ich mittlerweile ich habe auch eine weile esp home ausprobieren aber ich bin mittlerweile
der ansicht wenn ich was fertiges nehme da nehme ich das motor und wenn ich was custom
brauche dann programmiere ich selbst also für mich ist esp home jetzt gerade nicht
so der habe ich da gerade nicht so den anwendungszweck für also ich nehme komplett fertige dinger
wenn es das gibt zum beispiel für die led steuerung nämlich wled haben wir nicht sogar
letztens den wled maintainer hier mal im stream was ich übrigens richtig nice fand also wled
ist auch poc das motor ist poc und für so custom sachen wie den wattchamp da muss ich
den kram selbst programmieren bei einigen steckdosen sogar anzeigen lassen und auswerten
eine datenbank schreiben ist aber nicht so genau deswegen lese ich vor allem die hauptzähler
aus da bin ich mal gespannt wie er das macht ich vermute mal mit einem ähnlichen sensor
wie ich nur dass er die er wird wahrscheinlich selbst mit infrarot leds machen weil er die
ganzen widerstände hinten dran hat kann man machen funktioniert auch echt ganz brauchbar
ja der ferrari zähler genau abgesehen von steckdosen kann ich natürlich auch thermostatisch
steuern oder die komplette heizung oder auch ich finde es ja cool wie viel ähnliche sachen
der zu zu zu meiner zu meinem set up hat oder die komplette heizung das auch nur wie span
heizung exakt so ein ding habe ich bei mir auch im keller mit dem opto opto koppler
von den dran ja genauso genauso wie das video muss ich mir speichern weil die leute fragen
mich ja öfters wie das mit der heizung heizung steuerung beziehungsweise heizung auslesen
funktioniert genau mit so einem ding so was habe ich auch vorne dran hängen bei mir
hängt dahinter den raspberry pi dran wie to wifi ok was hat er da am start muss man
gucken vielleicht gibt es ja da was besseres als was ich habe mittlerweile wie to wifi
ach guck mal es gibt achso das ist mit dem microcontroller stels ich habe die raspberry
pi variante genommen ich verwende das auf raspberry pi ja ich benutze wie control d
und die haben und er hat wie to wifi gut es ist sicherlich geschmackssache der grund
warum ich das mit einem raspberry pi gemacht habe ist auch folgender ich habe einen offiziell
relativ günstig so ein offizielles wie es man opto link kabel bekommt für 30 euro
oder was immer noch viel zu viel ist ist ein kabel mit zwei mit zwei infrared leds vorne
dran ja und raspberry pi 0 hängt bei mir dann oben hier in der eck über der heizung
und er hat es anscheinend mit aduino oder esp gemacht und ich habe es halt mit einem
raspberry pi gemacht weil der usb hat und usb an esp 32 dran kriegen geht halt nicht
so ohne weiteres außer man nimmt einen von den neuen da gehts halbwegs aber dann brauchst
du immer noch den passenden treiber und die passende firmware und sachen dafür und du
musst wahrscheinlich viel selbst machen deswegen habe ich einfach was fertiges auf raspberry
pi genommen und gut ist mich würde interessieren ob es davon neue varianten gibt anscheinend
ja guck mal ok letztes update mai ne ja was denn jetzt port zwei hier mai 2020 aber das
ist wahrscheinlich eh schon dead wieder ja interessant ja ich finde es cool dass noch
andere diesen graben gemacht haben ja so wie gesagt so sieht es bei mir im keller auch
ungefähr aus was ich witzig finde dass dass man unabhängig auf relativ ähnliche lösungen
kommt oder auch ältere heizung ja das kann man machen so was muss ich bei mir zum glück
noch nicht machen ich habe mir einen switchport gekauft das ist quasi in den wifi gerät was
für die schalter drücken kann das geht ja es ist natürlich viel cooler wenn man selbst
eine schnittstelle an diesem zähler hat und das abgreifen kann magnet sensor magnet ja
das geht das geht am magnet sensor wollte ich nicht verwenden oder generell mit magnet
weil nicht dass die noch mir irgendwie vorwerfen ich würde das ding manipulieren es gibt ja
so diese diese tricks manipuliere deinen stromzähler mit magneten was übrigens unterm strich nicht
funktioniert beziehungsweise dass sie das merken oder habe ich kein bock dass irgendwie
einer sagt sie haben da was magnetisches dran gemacht sie wollten uns bestimmt bescheißen
wie hast du das mit den somfis sachen gemacht ich habe mir ein zeige ich dir was ich mir
gekauft habe somfie blinds und ich zeig dir erstmal was ich was ich für ein hab noch
so und so ein old school f 433 so ein ding ich habe noch so richtig old school dinger
von 2013 das sind das sind die fernbedienung dafür da ist noch nicht smart dran oder habe
ich mir als empfänger habe ich mir gekauft ein f x kommen oder so 433 e bleibt an der
zähler stehen ja wenn stark genug magnet machst schon so ein ding habe ich mir gekauft das
aber verboten das ist aber verboten und das merken die auch so ein teil habe ich mir damals
gekauft und die können dieses somfie protokoll da musst du den ihre software installieren
und einmal und einmal mitschneiden wenn du die die blinds hoch und runter machst und
dann lernt der was du was die für ids brauchen und da kann er diese diese die passenden somfie
rolling codes schicken und dann kannst du deine somfie dinger damit steuern es gibt wohl mittlerweile
auch für ein esp custom projekte auf github die das auch versuchen nachzubauen aber damit
ist eigentlich am einfachsten gewesen und das ist geht auch durch alle wende durch da
kann ich ganze hause mit steuern ja das ist das ist tatsächlich tos gar nichts wenn es
keine energie spart und das muss natürlich auch messbar sein wie es muss energie sparen
ich finde schon geil wenn es einfach geht klar natürlich ist sinnvoll energie zu sparen
immer aus dem erst mal für die umwelt und zweitens weil es weniger kostet aber ich
finde es allein schon cool wenn es funktioniert das ist für mich schon oftmals grund genug
ist was zu machen einfach weil es eine coole lösung ist und geht da dank notrad mag ich
nicht eine eigene app braucht ist es perfekt integrieren und automatisieren notrad mag
ich nicht weiß viele mögen notrad sich sachen zusammen zu klicken also ich mache das meistens
so entweder kann ich das über eine eingebaute home assistant automation machen oder aber
ich mache irgendwie custom custom python oder sonst wie weil ich finde es viel einfacher
in der ordentlichen programmier sprache logik abzubilden anstatt in notrad workflow zusammen
zu klicken ich bin kein großartiger notrad fan integriere und automatisierbar open source
halt jetzt kann ich also zum beispiel die garage aufmachen wenn die sonne scheint und
der 3d drucker fertig ist das kann man machen gemerkt war nämlich nur ein test ob du noch
richtig zuhörst ein sinnvolleres beispiel wäre die springleinlage nur dann zu schalten
wenn die wo ist das problem so ist doch gar nicht so unsinnig die trend die garage auf
zu machen wenn der 3d drucker fertig ist da geht der ganze gestank raus bevor man seinen
druck abholt ein sinnvolleres beispiel fest ob du noch richtig zuhörst die drucker fertig
ist so ist doch gar nicht so unsinnig da geht der ganze ganze 3d drucker gestank raus gemerkt
war nämlich nur ein test ob du noch richtig zuhörst ein sinnvolleres beispiel wäre die
springleinlage nur dann zu schalten wenn die freien daten des wetterdienstes keinen regen
vorhersagen ja das kann man machen 123 zuerst war die idee aber die idee ist auch nur 5 prozent
und jetzt denkst du dir toll jetzt muss ich auch alles selber machen oder wie eigentlich
nicht den großteil der entwicklung hat die open source gemeinschaft und auch ich dir
ja schon abgenommen ja man muss man das funktioniert leider nicht so gut es baut jeder recht individuell
individuelle lösung für sich also von sowas wie tas motor und so abgesehen dass du eigentlich
nicht die custom firma die einer für seine garagensteuerung oder seine 3d drucker springleinlage
gedürnt gebaut hat bei dir eins zu eins so verwenden kann du kannst ihr aber abgucken
und das ist das gute da dran wenn es open source code auf github github gibt du kannst
dir einfach abgucken wie es funktioniert weil viele sachen sind nicht sonderlich klar gerade
wie man manche geräte absteuert in welchem intervall man da was hinschicken muss wie
schnell man da auslesen darf bla bla bla also das ist auf jeden fall sinnvoll sich das
abgucken zu können man muss trotzdem vieles selbst machen zeitverschwendung das rad neu
zu finden dennoch muss etwas passieren wir wollen keine abhängigkeit von großkonzern
oder die ungewissheit die meisten haben kein problem ich will es aber auch nicht technik
und daten die wahrlich uns gehören wahrlich was ist wenn das internet weg ist was ist
wenn ein dienst wenn das internet weg ist und manche leuten hatten diese komischen thermos
tate die über aws laufen da konnten sie ihre heizung nicht mal anschalten das war auch
lustig das ist ein grund warum ich das total bescheuert finde sogar bei meinen aufnahmen
passiert ist hey siri schalte fernseher was bist du für ein loser siri
genau diese probleme die hat man nicht wenn man das offline hat das stimmt da hat er recht
da gebe ich im follow ganz recht ich bin auch kein großer fan von heim automatisierung
mit voice assistance ich habe kein alexa und kein dings wie heißt der konkurrent von google
also wie heißt die echo die echo dinger von google google google home google home genau
die auch so komische komische lautsprecher und so haben wir nicht cortana cortana ist
die microsoft geschichte für die es eigentlich nix gibt außer unter windows zu nerven ja ich
verwende ich verwende siri nicht aber ich verwende auf meinem iphone verwende ich schon
ist siri shortcuts was mit siri eigentlich wenig zu tun hat das ist die die reprandete
shortcuts ab die früher workflow oder workflow oder so wie ist das früher das hieß workflow
dann hieß es shortcuts dann hieß es siri shortcuts die haben das irgendwie dreimal
umbenannt und das verwende ich zum beispiel wenn ich nfc tags scanne um damit sachen auszulösen
ja zum beispiel um einen heizlüfter auf dem klo einzuschalten wenn ich den nfc tag an
dem klo papier behälter scanne mit dem iphone hey axel kannst du den fernseher anschalten
nexo style war dankeschön für den sub das habe ich mir auch mal angeguckt da das hat
mich noch nicht wirklich überzeugt du musst dir nämlich eins du musst dir quasi so so
du kannst selbst so geräte basteln da ist wahrscheinlich raspberry pi zero oder irgendwie
so was drinne was mich da ein bisschen abgeschreckt hat ist dass du bis heute nicht dein smart
phone lautsprecher verwenden kannst um befehle zu sagen smartphone smartphone mikro verwenden
kannst um befehle zu sagen das verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht warum das warum das nicht
funktioniert muss ich gerade mal gucken vielleicht geht das ja mittlerweile weil das wollte ich
mir auch schon mal angucken für sprachsteuerung archivet warum ist das archivet achso warum
auch wie warum auch weil ich immer mein handy dabei habe und ich nicht gerade in der nähe
von irgendeinem lautsprecher stehe also frage warum für sie weil du dein handy in der hand
hast und einfach eine taste drücken könntest und was sagen und beim anderen musst du dann
irgendwo hinlaufen und was zu sagen so gibt es da mittlerweile die möglichkeit das übers handy zu machen anscheinend glaube immer noch nicht glaube
das geht immer noch nicht oder mal schauen
oder oder geht das mittlerweile
entfacht
ich glaube es geht immer noch nicht
es geht nicht darum dass du gerät in die hand nehmen muss es geht darum dass du dein gerät in
der hand hast und kratz und mal angenommen du setzt dich aufs klo und willst den sprachkommando
abgeben entweder baust du in dein klo den lauten mikrofon ein oder du hast eh dein handy dabei
und rückst du auf den knopf also es ist bescheuert man kann das man kann mein wegen sagen hey man
braucht es in 90 prozent der fälle nicht aber es gibt eigentlich keinen sinnvollen grund zu sagen
man möchte nicht das handy als mikrofon nehmen weil ein handy hast du immer am start dabei
hast du immer auch abends wenn du im bettlicht oder wenn du im mein wegen auf der terrasse
bist oder so es ist es ist für mich so ein ding solange das nicht mit dem handy geht weiß ich
nicht ob das so sinnig ist ja beim nächsten mal kostet es keine chance deswegen auch siri
oder alexa bekommen hier bald haus und automatisierungsverbot und wir bauen stattdessen
einen cloud freien axel oder wie auch immer also ein excellent bauen war 3.de newsletter da gibt
es exklusive inhalte wie zum beispiel den zugang zu einer abstimmung wo du angeben kannst welche
themen dich am meisten interessieren nur so kann ich wissen wo es genau sich überhaupt lohnt meinen
total chaotischen code aufzuräumen prototypen zu verbessern und tutorials erstellen software
problemlos und schnell kopieren kann hardware jedoch nicht ganz so einfach und lötarbeiten
beispielsweise ziemlich viel arbeit in anspruch nehmen ist das seine steuerung für die für das
schloss sieht ein bisschen so aus das ist der das ist das ding für den motor das ist der demont
mini das ist der bluetooth ding das wahrscheinlich die steuerung für sein sein schloss würde ich bei
entsprechender nachfrage für klingel beziehungsweise klingel kamera das tierschloss und stromzähler
auch fertige hardware oder zumindest fertige platinen anbieten zu einem fairen preis bietet
das denke ich auch einen großen mehrwert ich mache das ja bereits seit einer ewigkeit also
bitte nicht vergessen den vermeintlich kostenlosen projekten wie wikipedia mozilla blender 123 js und
linux foundation und so weiter etwas zurückzugeben in welcher form auch immer denn du kannst nur
wirklich dann unabhängig bleiben wenn du weißt dass du nie wirklich unabhängig sein kannst
den motto sollte die hand die einen füttert nicht verhungern lassen ok ja aber nice video ich finde
witzig dass wir auf total viele sachen auf ähnliche ähnliche lösungen kommen sind aber gut bei so
sachen wie der wiesmann heizung und so da geht es ja auch wahrscheinlich nicht viel anders
ok this week in gaming wir lassen uns jetzt mal eine runde von level cap ci baiten wessen wetten
da kommt nichts bei rum das sagt im prinzip random sachen zu battle field 6 die wir eh schon wissen
also dass man nichts weiß und danach kommt was sinnloses hier in this week in gaming we have a
recap warum ist eigentlich das gameplay von level cap das war doch früher so eines der original
battlefield leute warum ist das gameplay mittlerweile so painstampig hatte er schon
immer so painstampiges gameplay so ein kill geschnitten ein kill geschnitten 50 mal geschossen
nicht getroffen ein kill geschnitten was hast du eigentlich auszusetzen ich will mich da jetzt
nicht zu sehr darüber auslassen aber nur mal so in der kürze also mein dass das was mir bei
next on am meisten auf dem kichs geht das nächste versucht alles zu machen und vieles total unfertig
ist die apps sind so 80 prozent und die restlichen 20 prozent die sie wirklich gut machen würden
funktionieren nicht da sieht man zum beispiel daran dass die notiz ab bis glaube ich bis letzte
version standardmäßig keine suche für notizen hatte ich meine man bietet ernsthaft eine notiz
ab an ohne suchfunktion das ist der witz mittlerweile geht es auch mit ordentlicher suche glaube aber
erst seit der letzten version es ist painstamp die meisten apps für nextcloud sind richtiger
painstamp was ist deine alternativier ich verwende den kram trotzdem immer noch weil so wirklich
habe ich da auch mich noch nicht weiter mit beschäftigt was man sonst machen könnte
wir wissen dass das wahrscheinlich im mai revealed wird ja müssen sie ja
genau genau genau ich habe immer leute ich habe immer noch echte zweifel ob die
taktik bei diesem battlefield wir schmeißen einfach mehr entwickler drauf ob das was bringt
da habe ich echt meine zweifel mehr ist nicht immer gleich besseres game everything is going
according to plan ea has an investor call scheduled for may 11th they'll probably reveal the game
after the call so prepare for a battlefield 6 trailer in the second half of the month a recent
survey allegedly sent by ea also hints at their plans for battlefield 6 it asks about free to
play modes map updates a battle pass and more assuming the survey is genuine it makes it seem
like battlefield 6 will include a free to play battle royale mode that gets seasonal map updates
firestorms failure to attract an audience clearly kneecap dice's plans for post long na ja die
haben sie ja mit firestorm auch mega verschissen ne dates firestorms failure to attract an audience
clear das problem an firestorm war ein einzig und allein also zumindest zu 90 prozent dass du
die spiel verkaufen musstest kneecap dice's plans for post launch support likely leaving a ton of map
updates a new content on the cutting room floor firestorm being behind a paywall and also associated
with a controversial battlefield title war critical factors in its demise dice going free to play with
battlefield sixes battle royale sounds like a smart move anders anders können sie es nicht machen
dass das alles das wird nicht funktionieren was ist das für ein ultra hässlicher panzer ja das können
sie machen also das einzige was sie machen können eigentlich das free to play machen den battle royale
teil was meine warum dass die mit warum die jungs das mit warzone gemacht haben bestimmt nicht weil
sie so spielerfreundlich sind und sagen ja wir wollen den leuten das spiel kostenlos geben
nee nur die mode will be free to play as well als ich wie das funktionieren for battlefield six to get a new battlefield battle royale experience modders are currently building a battle royale mode for battlefield three using Venice unleashed habe ich auch gelesen aber ganz ehrlich wenn es ist so dead und ich bin mir nicht sicher ob da dran überhaupt was entwickelt wird noch wenn du geht hab issues anguckst sie haben das hat irgendwie december nicht mehr darauf geantwortet weil wir immer gespannt als nächstes kommen
der battlefield drei reality mod raus der wohl auch relativ weit fortgeschritten ist das auch wenn es basis
vielleicht kriegt dann wenn es wieder ein paar spieler weil aktuell ist es komplett dead
mod tools they released a brief teaser this weekend it looks very ob das jemals fertig wird mal gucken as the mod is updated before we get to our next story here's a word from today's sponsor today's video is sponsored by geology personalized skin care from
i think it's safe to say we're all gamers here and that the gaming lifestyle isn't always okay da das brauche ich auch mal irgendwann noch skin care for gamers muss ich auch werbung für machen that makes it easy to maintain healthy looking skin lack of vitamin d sweaty gaming conditions i'm right there with you plus i've always been somewhat clueless when it comes to taking care of my skin hast du dir schon mal ein sponsor blog angeschaut ja aber das mache ich hier nicht rein weil wenn ich schon videos zeigen dann sollen wir ein bisschen was verdient
ran do i apply them how much time okay jetzt gebe ich das trotzdem alle wie lange geht dieses placement alter what the fuck available api to give players key insights about their matches like the average skill of the lobby the individual skill das war jetzt die news dreieinhalb minuten von 850 und nichts gesagt what the fuck
ok wie das jebaited for level cap you got jebaited got jebaited alter tribulan 16 monat dankeschön für den sub das ist ja excellent hypersubscription
das haben wir schon geguckt so was kommt uns als nächstes an youtube demands all die ja gut das kennen wir schon wie was umgehen können wissen wir auch
tiniest nvme ssd rate smart home wie upload filter ab juni das internet für immer verändert ok das zeigt man ja was der 1999 bericht
das ist bestimmt wahnsinnig cringe wobei ich eine sache sagen muss also ich bin der meinung dass es wenn man sich so alte berichte anguckt damals haben die
leute die die moderatoren die da am start waren die haben offensichtlich nicht verstanden um was es geht aber die haben auch nicht so getan als verstehen sie es die haben
dann so ein bisschen auf cool gemacht und das war es das war das war nicht so richtig cringe das war das war eher komplett nicht verstanden heute ist es so heute tun viele moderatoren oder viele
sendungen so als würden sie es verstehen aber sie verstehen es nicht und tun aber so dass es richtig cringe ist wisst ihr was ich mein ob man das jetzt ich glaube dass
ich jetzt zu konf konfus erklärt was ich mein wir gucken uns jetzt einfach mal gucken ob das stimmt was ich gesagt habe das ist auch geil das war die zeit wo die konsolen
irgendwie noch in bitt ich habe bis heu ich habe ehrlich gesagt legit keinen plan auf was sich das überhaupt bezogen hat 32 bitt konsolen 64 bitt konsolen 128 bitt
konsolen auf was hat sich diese bittanzahl eigentlich bezogen die cpu architektur war es nicht
adressen für irgendwas ich habe keine ahnung was hat sich das überhaupt bezogen mit der einzigen 128 bitt konsolen hat segar seit oktober bei den
videospielen technisch die nase formen im frühjahr starten wir sind das mit dem rauch segar die aufholjagd auch bei den cd das ist doch das ist rauch ok
damals damals hatte hatte lara noch big boobs und kaum was an gesamt 100 spieletitel bis ende des jahres 499 mark für die konsole der
gamecube ne nicht der gamecube der dreamcast controller ist das steht ja auch da drauf gamecube kontrolle sieht ganz anders aus
mit der man auch online gehen kann ja konnte man es war glaube ich einer der ersten wo gab es das erste fantasy star war das die
dreamcast war das der erste online mmo dinger mit 3,9 millionen verkauften playstations in deutschland bleibt sony der marktführer
ja wie kermit und fozzi bei der neuen mappet race mania verfolger mit neuen software titeln abhängen
ganz klar huge verkaufsschlager neu auch der fahrsimulator gran turismo 2 der fahrsimulator alles sony verspricht dass alle 800 software titel
der playstation 1 auch auf dem 128 bit nachfolger laufen einen prototyp gibt es bereits noch nicht für die öffentlichkeit doch die playstation 2 mit dvd
technik wird bereits abwärts in japan zu haben sein preis sony sony die musik dabei das soll sich so richtig schon abgespaced anhören
neuen system dolfin mit 400 megahertz technik das der gamecube ja noch sei die n64 konsole nicht ausgereizt was man mit spielen wie dem neuen
excite bike 64 beweisen will dank des gameboys ab 99 mark bleibt nintendo bei den gesamtstückzahlen verkaufter video spiel
der gameboy hat echt nur 99 mark gekostet damals der gameboy color ich dachte das ding wäre viel teurer gewesen
aber auf der anderen seite damals war es auch nicht ungewöhnlich dass man 20 plus gameboy spiele hatte
die systeme die nummer eins der hit pokemon das kultige abenteuer so schlecht wie er das ausspricht
das war richtig schlecht der kultige abenteuer ist der video spiel systeme die nummer eins der hit pokemon das kultige abenteuer spiel
das kultige abenteuer spiel auch der flipper pokemon pinball ab april gibt es für nintendo 64 zu hause pokemon stadium
ja der clue mit dem transfer pack können die gewünschten pokemon vom gameboy auf den fernsehbildschirm übertragen werden
doch damit noch nicht genug demnächst gibt sogar den ersten pokemon kinofilm
diesen 150 fantasiewesen aus dem neuen gameboy kult spiel ist jetzt sogar der sprung in die wette
die hat keinen plan wovon sie spricht wirklich absolut nicht aber man muss man muss man diesen moderatoren von damals zu guterhalten
die haben auch nicht so getan als hatte hätte sie ahnung wovon sie spricht ich finde heute ist das viel cringiger
weil die so tun als wissen sie wovon sie reden haben aber keine ahnung
als yo-yo als schlüsselanhänger als bretspiel oder als spielkarten und den knutlichen gelben pikachu gibt es sogar als spielfigur
der hier kann mit den oren wackeln und ein bisschen die nase rümsen
plüsch mit action
den typ haben die doch dafür die kamera platziert oder stellen sie sich mal hier hin und klicken und klicken sinnlos auf dem controller rum
oh gott furby dinger fuck das gab es ja auch zu der zeit
das war auch so ein grausames teil furby gibt es den kram überhaupt noch
ok das gibt es immer noch
fuck ist das teuer mittlerweile what the fuck
warum kostet das 300 euro
schau dir mal das hier an
zeig mal was ist das
woodface
hyperpains gem
a couple of them have gone back to sleep
das ist ja grausam das ist ja absoluter pains gem
das ist folter
oh ne das kann ich mir auf dauerlich geben
so schauen wir uns jetzt an
das klingt nach übelstem ich weiß was was ich nicht weiß titel aber mal gucken es gibt es gab hier mal das gerücht dass du wenn es diese upload filter sachen geben wird dass dann reaction videos nicht mehr möglich sind da habe ich aber so meine zweifel
das ist ja noch als wir damals verhindert haben dass das internet gelöscht wird und ihr habt es ja schon im titel gelesen und zwar würde youtube 2019 wahrscheinlich nicht mehr geben das ist zweieinhalb jahre her und youtube ist immer noch da wir haben es geschafft fünf millionen unterschriften wurden gegen die europäische urheberrechtsreform gesammelt 200.000 menschen gingen nur in deutschland auf die straße ich kann nicht lauter machen hat sogar den dritten weltkrieg video so leise
was ist denn so schlimm denn was wir ja erkämpft haben ist dass es keine upload filter geben wird hier das habe ich sogar auf der website von der cdu gesehen was meinst du mit ich soll die seite nochmal laden ja bis hierhin kennt ihr die story vermutlich noch die viel zu simple kurzfassung upload filter werden kommen das gibt sogar die cdu inzwischen auf dieser seite
zu denn plattformen haften in zukunft dafür wenn nutzer und nutzerinnen etwas urheberrechtlich geschütztes unerlaubt hochladen sind sie gerade wirklich anzeige ist raus auf einer spielstraße gefahren das ist ein weiterer strafzettel für audi die dieses auto gebaut haben natürlich
alle die in ihrem leben schon mal im internet waren haben relativ schnell erkannt dass das zu ganz neuen problemen für das wird also wenn das wenn das wirklich so in der erfassung kommt ich glaube eine sache was passieren wird was man jetzt schon teilweise ist komplettes
overplogging also sprich es wird lieber zu viel geploggt als zu wenig was ja aus google sicht da klar ist man möchte ja sich nicht angreifbar machen manche mehr als andere du hast nichts zu artikel 13 geleistet
die reform auf ebende muss ja dann erst im jeweiligen land umgesetzt werden und da sind wir jetzt in den nächsten zwei monaten muss die auch in deutschland umgesetzt werden inzwischen gibt es sogar einen entwurf vom kabinett der jetzt wiederum diesen freitag zum ersten mal im bundestag diskutiert werden soll und von den protesten von damals hört man da leider gerade gar nichts was ich also heute klären will ist bei der way
das wollte keiner und das gibt es jetzt zeitumstellung abschaffen wollten 84 prozent und das gibt es nicht so kaputt gemacht wie damals behauptet und wenn ja können wir daran überhaupt jetzt noch was ändern kapitel eins ist das das ende von den mal von dem ganz ehrlich das wäre ja für mich sogar ein positiver punkt weniger
reacts sind tatsächlich oft urheberrechtsverletzungen youtube bietet mir jetzt schon an reactions die andere auf meine videos machen mit wenigen klicks im creator studio weg zu streiken und könnte das dann heißen dass in zukunft es einfach keine
try not to laugh challenges keine tiktok highlight videos und keine reacts mehr gibt stimmt das das wäre ja richtig kacke für unge aber lebt unge nicht auf madeira und das ist in portugal also würde dann die portugiesische auslegung der reform gelten das bringt
mich ehrlich gesagt auf eine idee robins dumme tips für content in 2021 dummer tipp nummer eins auswandern wobei man wahrscheinlich gar nicht auswandern muss sondern es wird wahrscheinlich reichen wenn die firma für die man quasi videos erstellt im
ausland ist jetzt bestimmt irgendwie trick 17 in der europäischen union aber wahrscheinlich muss man in seinem account einstellen ja gut gute frage keine ahnung wie die urheberrechtsreform steuern oder menschenrechte
wer braucht wer braucht menschenrechte inhaber können eventuell trotzdem die inhalt dort sperren lassen wo sie abrufbar sind das heißt ja dass sowohl unge als auch die in dubai das gleiche problem wie wir haben aber dann denken wir dieses
horrorszenario doch mal weiter in zukunft sollen ja kurze ausschnitte als mutmaßlich erlaubt gelten das heißt der upload filter zündet erst wenn eine grenze überschritten ist wo ist die grenze weiß man nicht die grenze
liegt bei audio und video aber aktuell nur bei 15 sekunden aber da kann man ja richtig viel zu sagen in 15 sekunden wo 15 sekunden videos super gut youtube shorts nummer zwei postet
deine reacts nur noch auf instagram reels tiktok oder dem neuen youtube shorts wie soll eine kleine hunde in die kleine tasche reinpassen mehr im nächsten passt okay wir können jetzt nicht mitfliegen wir haben kein cpr test und so wie die haben gar keinen pcr test gemacht mehr im nächsten passt
wie das geht trotzdem nicht weil der rechte inhaber auch bei dieser nutzung direkt informiert wird und es dann sperren lassen kann wenn ich ein langes video einfach in zig kleinere zerschneide ach mist gut dann reagiere ich eben nur noch auf ganz viele tiktok shorts und die sind ja schon von vorne rein vielleicht nur 15 sekunden lang dummer tipp nummer drei react nur noch auf kurz videos wie das geht auch nicht weil man in zukunft maximal 50 prozent
eines fremden werkes benutzen darf nummer tipp nummer 4 reagieren nur noch auf halbe reels ach ist auch egal denn das gilt alles nur wenn keine erheblichen einnahmen erzielt werden dann fallen all diese ausnahmen ganz weg nummer tipp nummer fünf nicht zu viel geld verdienen warte mal wieviel sind denn überhaupt erhebliche einnahmen habe ich sie gerade richtig verstanden sie haben mit diesem einen video 100.000 euro verdient ist es immer noch eine erhebliche menge wenn man das
pro tag verdient frage für einen freund tatsächlich ist das eine sache die wahrscheinlich erst vor gericht gehen muss bevor es dazu aussagen geben wird aber wovon wir ausgehen können ist das für youtuber und youtuberinnen die das beruflich machen all diese ausnahmen wahrscheinlich nicht gelten und das ist tatsächlich eine sinnvolle trennung weil das bedeutet dass ihr als nicht kommerzielle nutzer und nutzerinnen das nutzen dürfte aber heißt das aber auch nur 15 sekunden beruflicher youtuber gar kein fremd material mehr benutzen darf
nein kapitel 2 zitate und parodien natürlich ist nicht jede nutzung von mehr als 15 sekunden gleich illegal zum beispiel gibt es ja zitate oder parodien die soll ich beim upload kennzeichnen können wenn der upload filter anschlägt sind aber wie gesagt oft keine zitate aber selbst wenn sie es wären wenn videos mehr als 50 prozent des originals enthalten werden sie vielleicht trotzdem gesperrt dummer tipp nummer 6 song parodien nur noch vom halben song machen oder
heute immer nur zur hälfte aus dem kontext zitieren und das könnten tatsächliches problem werden in zukunft könnten videos gesperrt werden die mehr als 50 prozent eines anderen videos beinhalten obwohl das eigentlich in dem moment
egal wisst ihr was ich da weil was die beschissenste sache daran ist dass sie das irgendwie auf youtube abwälzen wollen das zu kontrollieren das wird dazu raus das wird darauf rauslaufen dass random ohne sinn und verstand wieder irgendwelche channels verschwinden weil sie den dritten strike kassieren oder irgendwelche videos verschwinden von denen in den youtube algoritmus denkt sie hätten dagegen verstoßen das wird ganz ganz grausame und wisst ihr was das geile ist es interessiert von denen die das verabschieden keine sau wohlgemerkt keiner wollte das es kommt
84 prozent waren für zeitumstellungs abschaffung es kommt nicht wenn ich zum beispiel was zitiere 50 prozent egal was es ist dem filter filter bedeutet kann ich auf mich kann ich auf mich selbst reacten geht das ich kann aber auf mich selbst reacten kann ich ja noch dass das video für immer gelöscht wird das heißt erst mal dass du bis zu einer woche warten muss bis die rechtsfrage geklärt ist wird zu deinen gunsten entschieden geht das video online wird zugunsten des rechteinhabers entschieden dann halt nicht und in diesem worst case scenario könnte es noch
ein bisschen seltsamer werden aktuell steht in dem gesetzesentwurf nämlich nur dass die plattformen verpflichtet sind eben eine option zu haben dass man wenn der upload filter anschlägt und es unter 50 prozent sind dass man dann sagen kann hey warte mal das sind zitat gewesen und dann muss es online gehen aber andere potenzielle legale nutzungen sind da nicht verpflichtend aufgeschrieben alles könnte das doch jetzt schon alles gar nicht mehr richtig kontrollieren ich habe schon lauter gemacht ich habe das volle pulle ich kann auch hier noch einen ticken lauter machen
das ist relativ laut du hättest eine lizenz dass du es nutzen darfst aber du kannst es wenn der filter dann anschlägt gar nicht auswählen ja es könnte passieren und dann müsstest du wieder warten und aber manuelles review die kommen jetzt schon nicht hinterher
dummer tipp nummer sieben keine news videos oder sonstige videos mit aktuellen themen machen zum beispiel auf reactions von videos die gerade viral gehen oder mit product placements für kampagnen die in einem gewissen zeitraum gebunden sind weil das wäre finanziell echt kacke
ok aber news videos oder kritische berichterstattung durch ausnutzung des urheberrechts zu unterdrücken das würde ja keiner machen ok es hat schon mal jemand gemacht in der vergangenheit haben spielefirmen negative reviews ihrer spiele gestrikt aber positive online genossen
ein kanal der kritisch über den türkischen präsidenten erdogan berichtet wird regelmäßig mit falschen copyright claims belästigt politische berichterstattung auf twitch wurde mittendrin unterbrochen weil jemand mit einer gefälschten domain unrechtmäßige urheberrechtsansprüche gestellt hat um gezielt demokratische kanäle zu behindern wer hätte das gedacht ok denkt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich das ist ja unglaublich schlimm aber das was ich hier gerade beschrieben habe ist wie gesagt das worst case scenario das scenario was vor zwei jahren oft an die wand gemalt wurde und
wichtig zu wissen ist hier eine elefante wenn wir eine sache gelernt haben ist doch dass so sachen in der regel fast noch schlimmer werden als man sie sich ausmalen konnte vorher
und vor allem und vor allem dass die rechteinhaber da nicht gegen vorgehen weil ganz ehrlich sollte der erste sollte der erste anfangen reaction content oder sollte da großartig streiken das ist ja eine riesen lawine ja die das nach sich zieht
da ist es reaktiert ja aktuell jeder auf den anderen der reaktiert und alle verdienen da dran gut die werden ja blöd wenn sie damit anfangen würden dann die hand diese sachen löschen zu lassen und da habe ich auch ein paar dinge drinstehen mehr als je zuvor warum weil die meisten leute damit kein problem haben im gegenteil manche leute werden dadurch erst richtig groß war ja uns zum beispiel hat dadurch extrem profitiert und auch in zukunft wird es so bleiben dass der rechteinhaber entscheiden darf ob er will dass seine inhalte geblockt werden oder nicht
bisher machen das viele nicht und deswegen kann man eigentlich davon ausgehen dass ich in zukunft wahrscheinlich auch nicht machen werden aber ja denke ich auch wenn rechteinhaber alles blockieren lassen dann wird das bei mancher lekarer nutzung sicherlich zu problemen führen fairerweise muss man dazu sagen dass wiederholte falsche claims auch dafür sorgen sollen dass man aus dem system raus fliegt und auch schadensersatz soll möglich sein nur gerade bei solchen eingriffen in die presse und meinungsfreiheit ist mir dann vermutlich ziemlich egal ob ich die fünf euro etzenseinnahmen die ich dadurch verloren habe
nachträglich noch bekomme genau definiert wie viel geld das dann nämlich potenziell sind das ist bisher unklar kapitel 3 texte und bilder nicht nur audio und video dateien haben eine grenze die sie vom upload filter schützen sondern auch bilder und texte texte bis zu 160 zeichen und bilder bis zu 125 kilobyte und hier sehe ich warum warum warum macht man das bei bildern in kilobyte als ich kilobyte und hier sehe ich tatsächlich ein
größeres problem als bei den reacts das ding ist ein tweet hat schon bis zu 280 zeichen dummer tipp nummer acht screenshots dieses bild mit den infos was man denn noch darf hat 43 kilobyte aber text mit 183 zeichen und ich blende es gerade in dem video ein in dem es weniger als 15 sekunden steht schach matthias tietzministerium um es mal klar zu sagen ich möchte hier nicht dazu aufrufen so illegal texte zu nutzen sondern darauf hinweisen dass wir in zukunft tricks
brauchen um bei legaler nutzung zu vermeiden dass uns filter trotzdem weg blocken weil die schranken lächerlich klein sind autorinnen und autorinnen haben zum beispiel schon angst dass sie bald keine leseproben ihre eigenen bücher mehr teilen können schon geiler
oder lag es ihnen erlaubt kapitel 4 live streams erst letzten monat ging eine story rum wo in beverly hills ein polizist angeblich verhindern wollte dass ein aktivist seine kritischen fragen an ihn live streamed in dem er angefangen hat urheberrechtlich geschützte musik auf seinem handy ok quelle weiß was weiß ich aber die die idee ist schon geil oder spiel urheberrechtlich das ist mein next level 5 headshot das ist ja schon das ist
6 hat alle das ist 11 hat das ist ja so big brain mehr fällt mir gar nichts zu einem platzter kopf kann ich in zukunft also live berichterstattung verhindern indem ich auf demos mehr als 15 sekunden musik spiele oder bei politischen kundgebungen ein längeres liedchen pfeife kann ich in zukunft montana black für immer von twitch verbannen lassen indem ich bei seinem
nächsten malterurlaub einen tweet aus drucke und in seine kamera also letztes vermutlich nicht aber tatsächlich ist das gar nicht so sicher denn eine sache ist bei dem text noch ein kleines bisschen problematisch noch ist unklar so ein bisschen welch
inhalte ist pro plattform denn betrifft müssten twitch und youtube jetzt auch nach texten oder bildern checken oder sogar nach architektur oder kunstobjekten die ja auch urheberrechtlich geschützt sind dann haben wir ein riesen
problem ja und alles was ich bisher angesprochen habe geht von einer grundlegenden sache aus dass upload filter überhaupt in der lage sind das alles korrekt zu erkennen und das wäre auch
architektur ja das wird das wird auch das hauptsächliche problem sein dass dann einfach auf gut glück vieles geblockt wird weil man will sich nie angreifbar machen youtube natürlich schwierig
denn schon jetzt gibt es ja probleme mit automatisierte erkennung von inhalten ein ton ist zu hören und wird verständlicherweise als ganzer song erkannt oder jemand nutzt was legal was andere aber auch schon vor ihm legal genutzt haben wie zb stockfotos und der filter denkt dann es wäre geklaut
so wie in diesem beispiel von family guy bei denen die serie einen youtube clip eingebaut hat und hinterher dieser neun jahre alte youtube clip deswegen eine strike wurde kapitel fünf was können wir noch tun upload filter werden kommen das lässt sich nicht mehr ändern die einzige chance ist noch dass der europäische gerichtshof artikel 17 für grundrechtswidrig erklärt die entscheidung wird aber vermutlich erst fallen nachdem ja total fehlender ist schon ein nationales recht umgesetzt haben die einzige möglichkeit die situation bis
dahin zu verbessern ist mithilfe des bundestags dieses jahr ist bundestagswahl und ihr könnt euren abgeordneten schreiben was ihr zu dem entwurf denkt bitte sehr respektvoll und positiv es geht darum zu gucken was noch positiv geändert werden
als ließ das da jemand zum beispiel wichtig dass die maßnahmen zum schutz mutmaßlich erlaubter nutzung auf jeden fall bei behalten und sogar ausgebaut werden es waren im früheren entwurf mal von 20 sekunden audio und video material und 1000 zeichen die rede 160 zeichen sind einfach lächerlich wenig nur der einfachen screenshot machen aber jetzt ja gelernt
rechtsrichtlinie ist länger und würde gesperrt werden wenn ein news anbieter den artikel darüber schreibt und den namen voller länge da rein schreibt und ich dann danach was dazu schreibe oder auch den namen reinschreiben das kann auch nicht sein
dass 90 prozent eines werks benutzt werden dürfen bevor die filter anspringen und ich nur 50 prozent und eigentlich müssten 100 sein so lange ich es legal nutze sonst sperren die filter regelmäßig legale inhalte für eine woche und bei so einer lösung könnten
verwertungsgesellschaften übrigens mein instagram real trick umdrehen wenn zum beispiel rechteinhaber videos in kleinen schnitzeln hochladen dann sind 50 prozent eines werkes ihr plötzlich nur noch wenige sekunden das passiert ja nicht
immer unbedingt zwingend mit böser absicht wenn ich ein highlight clip mache von einem längeren video ist das ja ein neues werk was dann wiederum nur zu 50 prozent genutzt werden darf und woher weiß er
in der mitte der filter ob das lange video das kurze video jetzt das ist auf dass er sich beziehen sollte ich finde es sollte außerdem verpflichtend dass es mehr möglichkeiten gibt was man beim upload als legal beweisen darf wenn der filter anschlägt aktuell steht da was von den gesetzlichen ausnahmen wie zitat und parodie aber es gibt ja noch viel mehr gründe warum filter unrechtmäßig es sollten alle es sollten alle beiträge wo von von öffentlich rechtlichen wo drinne steht quelle youtube müssten die leute gleich erstmal striken man hat eine lizenz gekauft der filter
da hat ein fehler gemacht jemand hat was fälschlicherweise geklämt ich will ja nicht jedes mal sieben tage warten müssen und aktuell ist der plan dass im mai der bundestag das gesetz verabschiedet ab juni soll es gelten es ist viel zu wenig zeit die braucht es den puffer weil vielleicht kann youtube sich das leisten weil sie schon content id haben das dann so schnell umzusetzen aber andere plattformen vielleicht nicht und zum abschluss welche internet euch noch ein gedankenexperiment mitgeben in zukunft werden videos bis zu sieben tage auf
line sein wenn es rechtliche unklarheiten gibt in diesem sieben tage prozess wird in zukunft ein wirtschaftliches unternehmen in vielen fällen sind das us unternehmen oder im falle von tiktok ein chinesisches über deutsches recht entscheiden die werden entscheiden wer recht hat in etwas so unglaublich komplexem wie urheberrecht es gibt ja bekannte urheberrechtsprozesse die an deutschen gut das heißt nicht unbedingt dass es das dann dass dann der china chinese da sitzt und das wirklich beurteilt die haben da bestimmt
irgendwelche lokalen typen aber die sind ja jetzt schon total überlastet was da hochgeladen wird irgendwie zu kontrollieren und da kommen dann so entscheidungen raus über semper video der über vpn was erzählt zu sagen das ist ein hacking video und er bekommt ein strike und so was klappt er jetzt schon nicht hat oft jahre gedauert und in zukunft soll das erst mal in sieben tagen ein unternehmen entscheiden und dabei entsteht ein weiteres problem das unternehmen haftet bei einer falschen entscheidung für den schaden und zwar bis dann irgendwann in gericht entscheidet heißt wenn
gericht drei jahre braucht und sie haben heute entschieden dann ist dann haften sie für die ganzen drei jahre und nun stelle ich euch folgende frage würdet ihr als wirtschaftliches unternehmen eher zugunsten von einem kleinen user ohne anwalt entscheiden oder zugunsten von einem multinationalen rechteinhaber mit einer armee von anwälten wo ist das risiko das sage ich das ist das was ich die ganze zeit gesagt habe das wird dazu führen dass einfach auf gut glück alles was irgendwie anstößt sich oder was das anschluss irgendwie da reinpassen könnte geblockt wird
und was dann unglaublich schwer den kram wieder freigeschaltet zu bekommen
wenn wir nicht zu sagen gibt eigentlich gar keine chance
das wird wahrscheinlich passieren
ich weiß nicht warum
müssen irgendwelche
hyper boomer leute
einem den ganzen kram immer versauen
hyper boomer longs hyper boomer lobby stonks leute
weil sie gewählt wurden das stimmt die sache ist plus die
du kannst ja glaube ich kaum jemand wählen
wo das nicht der fall wäre
wen sollst du wählen dass das nicht der fall wäre
es erzählen dir alle im vorfeld dinger
die sie dann nicht machen das ist das ist standard schon
kannst höchstens die piraten wählen oder so
wenn so was geht ja
oder mich
aber du willst du wirklich der herzhaft wählen für
das problem ist
ich glaube es gibt niemand den du wählen kannst dafür weil spätestens wenn in der
regierung sind
klappt das wieder nicht guckt euch die grünen in hessen an was sie großartig
angekündigt haben
kein terminal in frankfurt nachtflugverbot flughafen ausbau bla bla bla
und nichts davon
wurde gemacht
ich persönlich finde das gut
weil ich ich finde es wichtig dass der frankfurter flughafen ausgebaut wird aber
als grünen wähler werde ich mir verarscht vorkommen
also da siehst du mal kann im vorfeld viel erzählen wenn der tag lang ist
und dann trotzdem nichts machen
das heißt ich gehe davon aus egal wenn du wählst es wird nichts es wird nichts
passieren in dieser richtung das wird einfach durchgedrückt werden
das sehe ich genauso florian leider gibt es keine partei wirklich
die mal eine vision hätte
das fände ich ja cool
hätten wir wirklich mal ein bisschen
visionäre sachen wo dann drin steht so sehr so so stellen uns die welt
2050 vor
und das sind unsere schritte und unser programm dahin zu kommen
wir könnten die poggers partei
egal wer regiert es ändert sich nichts ändert sich relativ wenig
das ist so ja
es ändert sich relativ wenig
die scrum partei
das ist gut wir könnten die die scrum partei der twitch chat wir machen einen
daily stand up
scrum
und kann man board
verschieben
partei champ
wir machen dann wenn es wir machen zur bundestag bundestagswahl auf jeden fall
wieder
den wal-o-mart
ich glaube wir haben es gar nicht so viel besser als die amis mit mehreren
parteien das hat alles so seine vor und nachteile
bei den amis ist ein vorteil den die auf jeden fall haben
die haben ja im prinzip die haben zwar auch mehrere parteien am plus zwei
nennenswerte
aber den lohnt bei den amis lohnt sich auch nicht kleine parteien zu wählen
weil
die die quasi in dem bundes
start gewinnen
geschlossen den gewinner wählen das heißt wenn du kleine stimmen das bringt
bringt bei amis nichts ja
deswegen gibt es ja auch plus zwei parteien
und die haben aber das ist gar nicht so übel
die haben den vorteil
dass die dadurch immer
eine halbwegs starke oppositionspartei am start haben das ist gar nicht so
verkehrt wie das die amis haben
da wird zwar immer viel gegen geflamet aber ich finde das auch nicht wirklich
schlechter als bei uns
du meinst bei gewinner und verlierer oder was
prozentual
ach so valomatt ja
ja gut wer macht wer macht den valomatt
nicht nicht die 90 prozent boomerwähler ja
ach nee
das ist ja auch nicht so
das ist ja auch das was mich so ein bisschen
wie nennt man das
nicht stur sondern so ein bisschen
was ist denn das, wenn man auf was kein bock mehr hat
ja das ist ja ich, das
nicht nicht konservativ, verdrossen verdrossen genau
Was mich so ein bisschen resigniert und verdrossen macht, ist...
Ich bin mittlerweile so für mich zu dem Schluss gekommen.
Das ist eigentlich egal.
Weil es wird eh keiner...
...was in meinem Interesse machen.
Deswegen ist das Einzige, was man machen kann, das ist das, was glaube ich auch immer mehr Leute mittlerweile auch zu dem Schluss gekommen sind.
Deswegen...
...auch die Gesellschaft unterlander immer unfreundlicher wird und immer egoistischer wird.
Weil die Leute zu dem Schluss kommen, okay, man kann sich nicht darauf verlassen, dass wenn es mir mal schlecht geht, sich mir irgend einer hilft.
Oder irgendwie einer mal was in meinem Interesse macht, so.
Und das einzige logische Konsequenz, die man daraus ziehen kann, ist...
...einfach gucken, dass man möglichst egoistisch ist und seine Sachen im Trockenen hat.
So fail ich das finde für die gesamte Gesellschaft, ja.
Aber es ist aktuell eines der wenigsten Sachen, die du machen kannst.
Du musst gucken, dass du deinen Scheiß geregelt hast, ja.
Dass du genug Geld hast.
Dass du halt alles das hast, was du brauchst.
Möglichst unabhängig von dem, was irgendjemand anderes für dich macht.
Ja, und natürlich macht es das und unter dem Strich macht es das sogar noch immer immer noch schlimmer.
Umso mehr Leute das auch so sehen, aber...
Man kriegt ja gerade gar keinen Grund, es irgendwie geliefert, oder immer mehr Gründe geliefert, das so zu sehen.
Ich finde es auch nicht gut, aber...
...du lernst halt immer wieder aktuell, überall, bei allen möglichen Entscheidungen, du kannst dich auf Aussagen nicht verlassen.
Es wird heute das erzählt, morgen das, heute wird das angekündigt, dann wird das andere gemacht.
Es wird A versprochen, es wird B gemacht, ja.
Ja, guckt euch zum Beispiel an, wie sie applaudiert haben für Supermarktangestellte und Krankenpfleger und sonst was.
Als könntest du dir von irgendwie dem Applaus was kaufen, das ist ja schön und gut, aber da muss harte Kohle rüberkommen, dass das da wirklich was bringt, ja.
Warum beschwert man sich, dass immer weniger Leute Krankenpfleger werden wollen?
Jetzt kommen sie auf die Idee, ja, gut, da müssen wir es für die Polen attraktiver machen, dass sie zu irgendwas machen.
Die logischste Sache wäre eigentlich, die Arbeitsbedingungen zu verbessern, dadurch mehr Leute zu bekommen, den Leuten mehr Geld zu geben, dadurch auch mehr Leute zu bekommen, und dann wird das Ganze wieder besser und das machen die Leute auch wieder.
Aber aktuell beschwert man sich einfach nur, die Leute lernen das nicht.
Und dann macht man so Kampagnen wie, ja, es ist ein wichtiger Beruf, hey es gibt genug Leute, die finden den Beruf wichtig und machen ihn auch, aber geben einfach nach 15 Jahren auf oder 5 Jahren oder was auch immer und sagen, ey das kann ich mir nicht mehr geben.
Weil gerade das, also Krankenpfleger oder im Krankenhaus, im Krankenhaus, in der Altenpflege oder sonst was, ist einfach ein Beruf, der ist geistig anstrengend, also belastend, ne.
Wenn du hast die Leute, die sterben, wenn du Leute, die krank sind, den Leuten schlecht geht, gerade wenn du so ein empathischer Mensch bist, was das ja auch noch eher Leute sind, die das machen, ja, also für die ist das geistig, psychisch belastend und es ist auch noch anstrengend und es gibt wenig Geld und man muss noch viel arbeiten am Stück.
Also warum sollte das überhaupt jemand machen?
Ja und es ist ja schön und gut, dass man da applaudiert, aber da muss immer ordentlich was rüber kommen und kommt wieder nicht.
Wo wir wieder beim Punkt sind, man, das sind die nächste Generation, die jetzt quasi lernt, ok, auf das was da gesagt wird, kann man sich nicht verlassen oder im Endeffekt kannst du dich nicht drauf verlassen, dass irgendwie einer mal was in deinem Interesse macht, was halt kacke ist, ja.
Dann werden permanent irgendwelche Aussagen getroffen, die danach wieder, danach wieder aufgehoben werden, so eins meiner Lieblingsbeispiel in letzter Zeit ist, dass die Aufenthaltsdaten, die man gesammelt hat in den Restaurants, als die Leute sich bei Corona eintragen mussten, wo man eintragen musste, ich war jetzt hier Burger-Futtern in Frankfurt, dann und dann Uhrzeit, Ort, Name, da hat man sich ja drauf verlassen, die Leute machen das immer wieder.
Weil es wichtig ist, die Leute haben das auch verstanden, dass es wichtig ist und man hat gesagt, ja, diese Daten sind streng zweckgebunden, das wird nur zum Nachverfolgen von Corona-Infektionsketten verwendet und was kam danach an Start, die Bayern haben gesagt, ach nee, Polizei kriegt auch Zugriff drauf.
Man hat gesagt, ja, diese Daten sind streng zweckgebunden, das wird nur zum Nachverfolgen von Corona-Infektionsketten verwendet und was kam danach an Start, die Bayern haben gesagt, ach nee, Polizei kriegt auch Zugriff drauf. Mag ja alles in gewisser Weise, nennen wir es mal, ehrenhafte Absichten haben, aber es ist unterm Strich die Leute verarscht und man muss sich nicht wundern, wenn das alles keiner mehr glaubt.
Ich meine ernsthaft, als diese, als in letzter Zeit, als vor ein paar Wochen rumgegangen ist, es haben sich irgendwelche Leute im Bundestag an dieser Mastengeschichte bereichert, war ja vor ein paar Wochen so Mini-Mini-Skandal, ja.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, danach haben die eine Ehrenerklärung abgegeben, wie ehrenvoll sie sind und dass sie das quasi nicht machen. Meint ihr, gibt es irgendjemand, der das für voll genommen hat? Also hat das wirklich irgendjemand beschwichtigt, der jetzt angepisst war?
Also, ich kann mich jetzt gar nicht vorstellen, dass irgendjemand sagt, ach ja, jetzt haben sie eine Ehrenerklärung abgegeben, jetzt ist natürlich alles gut, jetzt habe ich da wieder Vertrauen drin, ganz bestimmt, ganz bestimmt.
Es ist so fake. Außerdem, was man ja auch gelernt hat, ist, dass dort keiner irgendwie, nennen wir es mal, Ehre besitzt oder die wenigsten. Da siehst du nämlich immer daran, wenn da einer mal Scheiß gebaut hat, wenn da einer mal Scheiß gebaut hat, es gibt keiner zu Scheiße gebaut zu haben, sondern es wird immer bis zum äußersten erstmal geleuchtet, dass man Scheiße gebaut hat.
So nach dem Motto, vielleicht erwischen sie mich nicht, vielleicht erwischen sie mich nicht, vielleicht erwischen sie mich nicht, dann gibt es dann unwiderlegbare Beweise, dass sie Scheiße gebaut haben, dann wird sich raus geredet, so nach dem Motto, das war ich nicht, das war mein Untergebene, der das gemacht hat und ich hab ihn auch schon gefeuert.
Und wenn es dann so stark ist, dass es so negative Auswirkungen hat für die andere Trommel rum, dann treten sie zurück. Was ist das? Das kannst du vergessen.
Das ist voll für ein Arsch. Und das ist das Problem und warum das keiner mehr glaubt und das kann ich auch keinem übel nehmen, das nicht zu glauben, das Problem ist, das führt dann unter anderem dazu, dass die Leute, die vorher noch halbwegs normal im Kopf waren, jetzt anfangen mit so Geschichten wie ich lass mich nicht impfen.
Ich kann das schon in gewisser Weise nachvollziehen, wenn du quasi jahrelang verarscht wirst bzw. immer Dinge erzählt bekommst, wo sich danach herausstellt, stimmt nicht oder man hat absichtlich Mist erzählt oder man hat es nachträglich umdefiniert, dass die Leute dann immer vertrossener werden und auch so irrationale Dinge sagen wie ich lass mich nicht impfen.
Ich kann das irgendwie nachvollziehen und da muss man sich nicht beschwerend drüber, man hat das Vertrauen selbst verspielt. Natürlich sind die Leute letztendlich bescheuert das nicht zu machen, weil man bestraft ja damit nicht irgendwie die Regierung, mit der man unzufrieden ist, man bestraft sich im Zweifelfall selbst, wenn man das kriegt oder Angehörige ansteckt oder sowas.
Es ist eigentlich bescheuert sich nicht impfen zu lassen, aber viele Leute sagen das aus dem Grund, sie sagen der Motto, ich bin enttäuscht, jetzt können die mich mal, ich lass mich nicht impfen. So als BÄM, jetzt hab ich euch mal gezeigt.
Es ist, das ist selbst dran schuld. Du kannst nicht den Leuten einfach jahrelang immer Scheiße erzählen und danach sagen, naja war doch nicht so, naja auch nicht gestimmt und dann irgendwie hoffen, dass denen die Leute noch was glauben. Auch das ganze hin und her wird ja nicht richtig erklärt. Das mag alles seine Gründe haben, zum Beispiel auch, dass man zuerst gesagt hat, alte Leute sollen nicht geimpft werden mit dem einen Impfstoff, danach das ausgesetzt hat und jetzt sagt sollen hauptsächlich alte Leute geimpft werden.
Das hat alles seinen Grund. Ich hab auch letztens was drüber gelesen, das ging glaube ich darum, dass Leute mit Nebenwirkungen eher jüngere waren als ältere. Das hat alles seinen Sinn. Ich sag gar nicht mal, dass da das alles gemacht wird ohne Plan.
Die Sache ist bloß die, wenn das dann noch dazu kommt, dass es verwirrend ist und man wurde in der Vergangenheit schon öfters verarscht, ja dann ist doch kein Wunder, dass das keiner mehr glaubt, oder? Wenn man sowas macht, dann muss man das wirklich äußerst ausführlich kommunizieren, warum das so ist.
Und es reicht nicht, dass man einfach mal das irgendwie erwähnt so nebenbei, ach by the way, deswegen machen wir das. Nein, das muss man wirklich richtig breit treten, dass das auch die Leute noch erreicht. Und noch was muss man auch mal dazu sagen, ich finde das auch nicht sinnvoll, dass das mittlerweile prinzipiell alles, was irgendwie ein bisschen kritisch ist, Verschwörungstheorie ist.
Weil man muss mal ganz ehrlich sagen, man kann Corona für bedrohlich und ein wichtiges Thema halten und gleichzeitig nicht mit der Politik der Regierung einverstanden sein, das geht.
Also es wird ja aktuell so getan, als wenn du nicht damit einverstanden bist, wie die Regierung was herrscht, bist du automatisch Corona-Leugner, was ja keinen Sinn ergibt. Du kannst ja durchaus sagen, alter ich finde Corona ist gefährliche Sache und ich finde auch wichtig, dass wir da was machen, aber ich bin mit diesen Punkten nicht zufrieden.
Das ist eigentlich das, was so in der normalen öffentlichen Diskussion eigentlich stattfinden sollte. Macht's aber nur teilweise.
Es gibt, ja das ist auch tatsächlich ein Problem, dass 2021 alles nur noch schwarz und weiß ist. Entweder du bist dafür oder du bist dagegen oder du bist links oder du bist rechts oder du bist sonst was, dass es Leute geben kann, die Sachen, die sagen wir mal die Linken und die Grünen erzählen, was weiß ich.
Also es kann durchaus Leute, was ich sagen will, es ist nicht nur schwarz und weiß. Man kann durchaus Dinge, die die AfD sagt in manchen Punkten, denen kann man zustimmen. Das macht einen nicht sofort zum Nazi.
Auf der anderen Seite kann man auch die gleiche Person für Umweltschutz und Sachen sein, die die Grünen sagen zum Beispiel. Das ist überhaupt kein Ding. Die Welt ist halt nun mal nicht schwarz und weiß.
So und wozu das meiner Meinung nach führt, dass das so schwarz und weiß gemalt wird, ist, dass die extremen Positionen einfach noch extremer werden.
Weil meint ihr ernsthaft, man überzeugt irgendjemand davon, indem man ihm sagt, deine Meinung ist scheiße oder deine Meinung interessiert uns nicht? Damit überzeugst du im Endeffekt keinen, egal von welcher Seite.
Das ist eigentlich wurscht. Also du kannst das schon noch sagen. Wir sind ja nicht in China. Du wirst ja nicht gleich verhaftet, wenn du irgendwas Falsches sagst.
Aber es ist unglaublich schwierig, da öffentliche Diskussionen drüber zu führen. Du musst da wirklich rhetorisch schon äußerst versiert sein, dass du kritische Sachen noch sagen kannst, ohne dass dir gleich einer ans Bein pisst.
Also du musst da schon wirklich sehr feinfühlig vorgehen und wenn du auch nur eine Sache falsch sagst, hast du gleich den wilden Twitterhaufen oder sonst wie an der Backe, der sich wie verrückt empört.
Also das ist nicht einfach gerade und deswegen kann ich auch verstehen, wenn viele Leute sagen, ey ich äußere mich zu kritischen Sachen nicht mehr öffentlich.
Hatte letztens auch einer bei mir einen Kommentar geschrieben, mich soll man ein Video machen zu irgendwas aktuell. Ich hab schon wieder vergessen zu was.
Da hab ich ihm auch bloß drauf geantwortet, ey es gibt so viele Leute, die sich direkt instand dran stören würden, mach ich nicht mehr.
Mach die FDP die ganze Zeit. Ja der Lindner ist halt rhetorisch was das angeht nicht übel, der kann das halt gut verkaufen sowas. Aber das kannst du und ich nicht einfach so.
Und außerdem gibt es auch das komplette andere Beispiel, es gibt genug Punkte, wo auf YouTube sich mal öffentlich einer, ich will jetzt nicht so sehr auf diesem einen Thema rumreiten, sich zu Positionen geäußert hat, wo beispielsweise die AfD dafür war.
Und du hast instand Leute am Start gehabt, so nach dem Motto du bist jetzt ein Kack Nazi. Das geht mittlerweile echt schnell.
Wobei man sich halt echt mal überlegen muss, nur weil jetzt jemand was sagt, was jemand anderes auch schon mal gesagt hat und dieser jemand anderes hat jetzt noch andere dumme Sachen gesagt, bedeutet das nicht automatisch, dass nur weil zwei Personen in einer Meinung übereinstimmen, automatisch beide Seiten alles übereinstimmen was jemals jede Seite gesagt hat.
Das wird ja auch ganz gerne gemacht, so nach dem Motto du bist für Punkt A, irgendein anderer ist auch noch für Punkt A, also bist du automatisch auch für alles was schlecht ist, was der jemals gesagt hat.
Doof, ja.
Und außerdem, und das Schlimmste ist, das Schlimmste ist, was mir persönlich am meisten auf den Sack geht, dass heutzutage wirklich jeder wegen alles und jedem Scheiß übelst empört ist.
Ja, also du kannst heutzutage alle krass empört sein. Und ich hab da nicht mal ein Problem mit, ich find sogar gut, wenn die Leute öffentlich empört sein dürfen, das ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Das können die auch machen, das ist ihr gutes Recht, öffentlich empört zu sein. Was ich dann problematisch finde ist, wenn da so extrem viel drauf gegeben wird, ich mein, ey, es gibt auch viele Dinge, die mich abfacken, über die ich empört bin.
Aber ich erwarte nicht, dass die ganze Welt sich dafür interessiert, dass der Max da jetzt drüber empört ist.
Naja, gut.
Wir sind mit South Park und Family Guy aufgewachsen, wie kann man da empört sein? Das stimmt. Wisst ihr, was mich wundert? Ich mein, South Park ist ja schon immer recht heftig, was die haben.
ihr was mich wundert ich war in south park ist ja ist ja schon immer recht
heftig was die haben hat jemand von euch die folge gesehen die south park folge
mit dem mit dem transgender muskelmann der bei bei bei der frauen sport
weltmeisterschaft oder sowas mitmacht
ich muss ja sagen south park haut ja gegen alles ja aber das ist halt so ein
ding da haben sie sich auch übelst rüber aufgeregt ich hab mir ich denke mir
halt alter es ist south park die machen sich über alles und jeden lustig und
machen dabei noch irgendwelche witze über scheißhaufen und sowas das so ist
das schon immer gewesen im endeffekt über all du kannst south park wirklich
nicht vorwerfen sie hätten da irgendwie so eine geheime agenda oder sowas die
machen sie wirklich über jeden scheiß lustig und trotzdem haben die leute
sich da wieder drüber übelst aufgeregt da gibt es dann auch reactions auf
youtube wo dann irgendwelche leute zu der south park folge reacten und sagen
irgendwie nach dem motto das muss man absetzen und sonst wie man da fack es
ist south park ist wie kann man sich ernsthaft über das aus park aufregen
hätten sich damals auch alle wo spieler drüber aufregen sollen dass in der in
der world of warcraft folge wo spieler fette alte säcke vom rechner sind ich
fand das lustig ehrlich gesagt ich war damals auch in den mmo grinder ich war
eigentlich damals jemanden hätte diese folge voll ansprechen müssen und die
meisten leute die south park kennen kennen die wo folge ja und ich habe
darüber gelacht du hast sicherlich die ein oder
anderen gehabt die sich da drüber aufgeregt haben aber es hat keinen
großartig interessiert man gesagt ja es ist halt south park ich ich fand es auch
nicht schlimm ich fand es echt nicht schlimm und im prinzip haben die genau
mich angesprochen damals ich war der übelste mmo grinder zu der zeit und ich
habe da teilweise auch gegessen vom pc halb geschlafen vom pc im prinzip genau
das wie sie in south park dargestellt und ich fand es lustig ja
genau wo ihm die mutter den klo die die kacke schüssel bringen wusste
ja gut also heutzutage wird schalt über alles empört was ich auch cool finde an
der folge viele leute kennen die south park world of warcraft folge aber sonst
nichts anderes also ganz viele leute war das erste mal als sie was davon gehört
haben die world of warcraft folge das hat bestimmt so viele neue fans gebracht
wenn ndl über gamer berichtet hat haben sich auch alle aufgeregt ja so ok können
sie ja machen aber das davon ist die welt nicht untergegangen hat sich bei
ndl da irgend einer wirklich für interessiert
weiß ich hatte hat ndl damals nicht sogar so einen so eine halbherzige statement
gepostet du kannst dich ja aufregen das ja vollkommen in ordnung und ich finde ich
finde auch gut dass man dass man dass sich öffentlich aufregen kann ist ja
schön und gut aber ich habe mich damals auch aufgeregt über das aber zumindest
habe ich ein video gemacht über das ndl video wo sie gesagt haben irgendwie
gamer auf der games kommen irgendwie alles nur verschwitzte nerds so nach dem
motorway sagen da ist auch teilweise schon ein bisschen was dran gewesen aber
natürlich nicht so wie das ndl dargestellt hat und klar dass ich da ein
bisschen drüber aufgeht aber dann war auch wieder gut ja es ist ein unterschied
ob man sich über den beitrag von ndl aufregt oder ob man sagt so nach dem
motto ndl feuert den ersteller der doko das ist ein unterschied und das ist das
was heute oft passiert wenn es bleibt nicht beim thema es bleibt nicht beim
thema um was es geht nämlich dass gamer eben nicht allgemein bei diesem ndl
ndl bericht bleiben dass gamer nicht allgemein verschwitzte ungewaschene
stinker sind sondern eben dass das dass das blödsinn ist was ndl erzählt hat
aber wenn ich jetzt sagen würde leute ndl ihr seid so scheiße ich bin so krass
offended bitte feuert feuert sofort die ersteller dieses beitrags das ist das
was heute passiert das finde ich kacke ich kann mich thematisch mit dem thema
auseinandersetzung sagen ich finde das scheiß und ihr habt mich recht und ich
kann mich auch darüber aufregen und öffentlich empören aber wenn ich dann
forderisch schmeißt die ersteller des beitrags raus das wäre bescheuert und
dass es damals nicht passiert ist auch richtig dass es nicht passiert ist
ja und das hast du heute das hast du heute du hast heute leute die rufen wenn
einer ein kritisches youtube video macht oder irgendwie sich kritisch die rufen
beim arbeit das ist jetzt jetzt denke ich mir jetzt nicht aus das ist ja
aktuell wirklich so die die gucken wo der arbeitet und rufen dort an und sagen
die sollen den feuern es gibt so verrückte leute muss man sich mal
vorstellen das ist einfach nur fail
genau genau peck peck peck exakt das ist das was ich was ich die ganz was ich
ganze zeit auch sage dass es viel zu viel schwarz und weiß gibt und es ist im
prinzip kaum was schwarz und weiß
ja aber auf die leute auf twitter wird ja reagiert das ist ja das das ist ja der
unterschied auf den riesen twitter mob der sich empört darauf wird reagiert
darauf wird was gegeben dass auf grund dessen werden sachen werden leute
will ich sagen gefeuert aber sachen eingestellt umgeschrieben sonst was die
habt das das hat ein fluss drauf wenn man sich auf twitter empört und wird
deswegen habe ich meine twitter trends auch umgestellt auf andorra weil ich mir
den kram gerade in deutschland nicht geben kann was da in den twitter trends
drinne ist das ist so fail einfach nur es ist es ist so anstrengend zu sehen auch
zu lesen noch schlimmer jetzt wird es über alles ultra empört dann hat einer
mal ein falsches wort verwendet und schon ist er gleich schlimmer ist er gleich
auf einem level mit irgendwelchen massenmörder nur weil er falsches wort
benutzt hat und so die also die leute sind heute es gibt gleich auf 180 ja so
normal normal aufregen gibt es nicht mehr es gibt nur voll extreme ganz das ist
echt total total bescheuert in der aktuellen zeit und ich hätte gar kein
problem darauf wenn die sich auf twitter aufregt aber es wird halt auch noch
viel drauf gegeben
das hat halt ein fluss
naja gut was auch immer aber ich bin da wahrscheinlich selbst zu boomer für was
das angeht ich bin in der zeit aufgewachsen leute 84 84 bin ich geboren
90 ja war ich war ich quasi jung da wurden keine facts given auf so gut wie
nix
es ist so also
90 war echt jolo jahrzehnt 90 ist wirklich komplett johlen jahrzehnt da hat
jeder gemacht irgendwas und
eigentlich war alles gut
90 war echt no facts given
kannst du fragen habe ich nicht end of function 0
gemm torp 18 was macht jedem stopp eigentlich
Naja das sind die hodl die hodl leute
Schau mal bitcoin kurs
oder ist wieder der ist wieder runtergegangen
der war noch mal fast bei 60.000 der war noch mal fast bei 60.000 dollar
noch heftig ja ich finde die game stop Geschichte ist eine coole sache das ist
auch so was wo viele schon wieder gesagt haben so nach dem oder nein das muss
man verbieten dass die leute sich auf reddit absprechen und ich denke mir da
nur so warum ich meine auf der einen seite hast du
irgendwelche forms mit mit milliardenschweren investor leuten und
managen die im prinzip nichts anderes machen und auf der anderen seite hast
du halt leute die nicht milliarden haben aber halt viele sind und
dementsprechend auch ordentlich kohle haben und warum ist das eine ok und das
andere nicht die storks menschen haben wir auf den sack gekriegt der damit
musste halt auch mal leben ja wenn du sowas mitmachst also das war auch wieder
sowas weil es da vorher als jemand da gab es da gab es ganz viele sachen auch
wenn du mal so in diesen wenn du so in den standards sachen guckst sei es jetzt
hier was weiß ich spiegelzeit sonst wie wenn er online so rumgeguckt hast gab es
viele so meinungs sachen da gab es ja diese die haben ja die haben ja nicht
nur nachrichten die haben ja auch so quasi so so meine fünf cent zum thema
von von manchen autoren da haben echt einige schrieben auf dem motto ja aus
ihrer sicht ist das ist das unverantwortlich und und ganz
furchtbar böse und das kann ja nicht sein dass es gegen den gedanken von der
börse und so dass sich leute auf reddit absprechen und ich denke halt nur warum
wieso auf der einen seite hast du richtig krasse milliarden storks leute die im
prinzip auch die sachen ja weiß ich auch so manipulieren nennen können und auf
der anderen seite hast du den ausgleich von vielen kleinen leuten auf reddit
wo soll da der unterschied sein dass das jetzt verstehe auch nicht ja also
das ist ich finde das ich finde das genau richtig wenn das milliarden
schwere storks leute können dann sollten das genauso gut auch hobby hobby anleger
auf reddit kann ja ok was gucken wir jetzt so ich habe ich krieg langsam
hunger aber dabei ist erst zwölf noch so viele witz die wir gucken können 20
minuten best of bell viel clips ok ich hoffe nicht so viele jets weil habe ich
keinen bock drauf smart home bild der hyper scale switch 400 gigabit 32
moment was 400 gigabit 32 sports wie viel kostet das ding warum hat sich
warum hat sich meine uhr noch nicht noch nicht gestellt oder hat sich meine uhr
gestellt warte mal ist es jetzt weniger oder mehr ich bin ich bin bin verwirrt
und uhrzeit 13 uhr was ist microsoft was ist los
wie kann man da kann man das forcieren irgendwie wie forst man den ntp zu
machen just a time so genau was da muss man rechte für machen jetzt geht's warum
ist warum warum ist windows manchmal so schlecht kann mir das jemand erklären
warum ist windows manchmal so schlecht verstehe nicht fragt bill gales bill
gales verwende wahrscheinlich selbst gar kein kein windows mehr ok was kommt
mal jetzt an battlefield newbill haus ok wir gucken uns noch die haustour smart
home geschichten an
den gucke ich immer gerne da hat neiste videos mal gucken aber hier auch was
ordentliches hat ob klopf herein noch noch it's me i kill you
da hätten sich heute auch trübe offen kennt noch eine achmed der terrorist
als ich finde immer noch eines der lustigsten programme in der richtung
ever it's ach ach achmed silence oder am geilsten ist das weihnachts special
habt ihr habt ihr mal das weihnachts special geguckt jingle bombs ich bin
so einer der geilsten programme überhaupt so die seite was der je
gemacht hat er hat ein paar andere witzige aber das ist echt eines der
geilsten knock knock it's me i kill you
hey welcome to our house sorry we haven't posted a while we've been super
busy moving out of our apartment and into the house but we're all moved in
now ich sag euch ich sag euch heute heute das programm neu so dass es die
leute noch nicht gehandhalten ja hätten sich auch wieder zig leute
drüber aufgeregt du kannst doch sowas nicht machen als programm hätten sich
total viele drüber aufgeregt mittlerweile regen sich da sicherlich auch
schon einige drüber auf aber nachdem das ein etabliertes programme ist nicht so
sehr aber wenn das heute neu gewesen wäre stellt euch mal vor der hätte
dieses der hätte dieses achmed the terrorist program heute rausgebracht
alter twitter wäre eskaliert die werden die werden wieder die welt ohne gang
gesehen aber mein lieblings also mein lieblings twitter shitstorm ich weiß
ich habe schon öfters erzählt aber der ist so unglaublich dumm das deswegen ist
mein lieblings twitter shitstorm mein lieblings twitter shitstorm war als in
overwatch rausgekommen ist in einem offiziellen comic das tracer lesbisch
ist tracer comic das tracer eine freundin in london hat kam in irgendwie
kam in einem tracer comic raus und ich dachte mir damals so ist doch so eine
coole sache für blizzard ja ist schon ziemlich diverse cast in overwatch
eigentlich eine coole sache aber nein die leute haben sich auf twitter darüber
aufgeregt dass es tracer ist und tracer ist ein charakter der explizit für das
männliche aure designt wurde da kann man doch nicht einfach so in einem comic
sagen dass die lesbisch ist da haben sich die gleichen leute die sich früher
darüber aufgeregt haben dass es nicht alles genug repräsentiert ist haben sich
dann darüber aufgeregt dass es die von den falschen rep da war ich echt
mindblown da war ich echt komplett mein po habe ich mir
gedacht alter man kann sich echt über jeden scheiß aufregen wenn man nur wenn
man nur will echt der wahnsinn das war so der der sinnloseste twitter shitstorm
aller zeiten den ich bis heute nicht verstehe über was man sich da einfach
aufregen kann wo ist der schwule charakter in overwatch er ist solcher
70 76 nicht schwul oder oder zumindest zumindest nicht abgeneigt
doch doch ich glaube solcher ist zumindest zweigleisig unterwegs laut
overwatch story frag mich nicht warum ich sowas weiß ich habe die overwatch
story lang zu lange verfolgt ja
es ist ja echt mittlerweile komplett dachschaden die leute gerade auf twitter
gerade auf twitter
die frage ist wen juckt das frage ich mich auch jedes mal wenn ich sowas lese
aber anscheinend juckt das genug und witzigerweise auch genug die mit dem
gelben zu tun haben
ok
ok wetten wetten dass das so ein typisches ami haus ist wo du einfach
mit einer schere gott faltest falsche mode wo du einfach mit einer schere und
lang genug zeit ein loch in die wand schneiden kannst
ist das ein beamer was er da stehen hat oder ist das eher so eine so eine
sound box wobei ein beamer unterm fernsee ist auch
nicht sinnvoll oder was ist denn das was hat er da stehen
die und nichts derftes habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen
sound wie man nach oben
ah das hier das heißt das ist gar kein klassischer beamer wo du vorne lampe
hast hier kommt das raus hier kommt das oben raus und beamt das dann direkt
oben hin ach so ok das sind die teuren das sind
die
hat ich mir auch kurz überlegt bin ich zum schluss gekommen
nope ich behalte das was ich da habe
eines der sachen die ich im leben nicht automatisieren würde ist meine
eingangstür
ein haustür wird nicht automatisiert
ihr wisst ich habe keine schmerzen hier bei mir in drinnen alles smart
haumtechnisch aus zu auszustatten und auszurüsten aber die eingangstür die
werde ich im leben nicht mit einem smart lock smart lock ausrösten
und decided what one i want to put on so das war ich bin dann aber der builder
install micu smart garage door openers so we've been using that we don't
want to bring our keys with us if we're just going out for a walk or something
all right let's go take a look inside welcome to the family room i love this
area because it's so open and you can see the kitchen from here and on here we
have the frame tv which we purchased and we got the 2021 version das ist ein
fernseher warte minute das ist nicht der kinoraum den
er vorhin gezeigt hat
and i love the frame tv because ist das ein fernseher oder ist es ein bilderrahmen
oder ist das ein fernseher der bilderrahmen faken kann
bilderrahmen mit bildschirm ok
it displays art when the tv is off so it's not just a black screen when you're
not watching tv and so we'll have some different pictures up next to it it'll
kind of blend in when we're not watching tv das ist ein fernseher
the remote that it came with it it has a solar panel on the back to charge it
which is kind of cool but the front das sieht aus ein bisschen wie die amazon
fire tv fern android tv fernbedienung
confusing i actually had to use the manual to figure out how to control the
volume on this is a little embarrassing but all the furniture hat samsung
eigentlich android tv auf den fernseher oder was haben die da
also bei sony sony weiß ich sony ist
sony ist android tv titsen haben die drauf ach genau ja
in here well at least for the entertainment area is from ikea with the
pandemic there was a lot less options a lot less options and then there was a lot
less option was war gerade an die roten pfeile da das ist irgendwie ich weiß
nicht wie es euch geht chat aber ich finde dieses wohnzimmer hardcore
ungemütlich das ist einfach nur in den riesen raum mit einem sofa drin
was options but i think this ikea furniture looks good as you can see i
still have some bookshelf setup okay hat auch nicht er hat auch noch nicht alles
aufgestellt but we're still adding some stuff here in the room and it's a
pretty big open area which will make it kind of a challenge with motion sensors
so moment das ist so und so und so ein wohnzimmer dahinten kannst du essen
schenkt kommt jetzt auch noch genau hier ist noch eine küche das ist quasi das
ist quasi so alles in einem raum küche essen und wohnzimmer und hier stehen
random einfach zwei stühle okay aber hauptsache denen gefällt es also mir
muss das ja nicht gefallen das ist das ist kokona das ist kokona style hier
kannst du nämlich einfach mit einer säge mit einer säge ein loch in die
wand schneiden das funktioniert bei uns schon mal gar nicht das stimmt schön
suche in die fahnen hast du nie wieder besucht naja ich gehe mal davon aus die
haben da schon dunst abzugshauben und und so was in der küche drin also es
wäre ziemlich blöde so ein offenes ding zu bauen mit küche und keinerlei abzug
in der küche zu haben
die vorteile von holzhäusern liegen auf der hand jaja wenn mal wieder einen
wirbelsturm kommt bei amis dann ist das haus weg ich finde das ist schon ein
großer vorteil das ist so was gibt es bei mir nicht geben ich kenne die videos
von immer ist ultra alexa fern
also ich bin gesagt dass da ist ja bin ich kein großer fan von also eins kann
wenn du sagst nach diesem nach diesem hurricane nach dem ordentlichen hurricane
ist das steinhaus auch nicht mehr bewohnbar also ich kann dir sagen das
steinhaus hier in dem ich jetzt wohne das hat ja nicht mein opa gebaut er hat
ja nur ausgebaut das hat quasi sein opa gebaut das ist schon ein bisschen älter
also das haus ist frag mich nicht 1900 oder so das hat den ersten und zweiten
weltkrieg überlebt gut im ersten weltkrieg ist da nicht so viel passiert
aber im zweiten weltkrieg sind ja auch ein paar bomben eingeschlagen also das
haus wenn das den zweiten weltkrieg überlebt hat das überlebt auch den
hurricane das stabil dafür habe ich das problem dass
ich an manchen stellen gar nichts in die wand schrauben kann weil so brutal hart
ist also zumindest nicht mit meinem normalen 12 volt akku schrauber
ich hatte ich hatte das problem bei meinem bei meiner werkzeug wand
das und saumäßig stabiler keller ohne scheiß der keller ist wirklich da hast
du gefühlt irgendwie meterlange steine halben meter hoch mittelang breit steine
also der ist wirkt als der keller der hält alles aus
hier hatte ich das problem bei meiner werkzeug wand
ich habe das ich habe vorher geguckt ob da mit so einem sensor kannst du gucken
ob da metall in der wand ist wer bohrt denn mit einem akku schrauber löcher in
der wand ja ich weil ich habe keinen bohrer ich habe nur diesen 12 voll akku
schrauber das geht normalerweise easy ist gar kein problem
ich habe alles mit dem akku schrauber dran gebohrt den ganzen stellst du auf
stufe 2 dann ist das eigentlich fast so gut wie ein ordentlicher bohrer so das
problem ist nur ich habe hier geguckt auch kein metall oder sonst was dahinter
alles gut aber wenn du an der falschen stelle bist die steine die steine sind
teilweise so extrem hart das kriegst du nicht richtig rein da bist du echt
eine viertelstunde am am akkern mit dem mit dem akku schrauber
ich habe aber keine da gehabt ich sag nur das ding war echt stabil
du hast ein playcenter im keller ne zum glück nicht
den kannst du am dritten loch wegschmeißen warum der hat das ding ist
stabil das ist gute quali das hat gar kein problem damit
ist das keine hol beton wand also sonderlich hol hat sich das nicht
angeführt an manchen stellen merkst du an manchen stellen bohrst du rein hast
ein bisschen widerstand und bohrst dann durch und dann ist ok keine ahnung aber
gerade an der außen wand das ist halt auch die die die wand die zur straße
geht ich habe mir da ein abgeleiert mit dem akku schrauber
ist das ein smart ist das ist das hat er jetzt erzählt aber den smart was ist
ein smart mikrowelle was der okay smarte mikrowelle wüsste jetzt nicht was an
der mikrowelle war sie nicht schmarrt sein soll
und so lange sich nest ist es alles gut weil nest ist pence camp
nest hatte auch letztens probleme wo das service nicht da war dass die leute
ihre heizung nicht verwenden konnte
was laundry rum ist der der raum für die wäsche oder mit der waschmaschine wasch
waschraum so was macht ein smart ok ich muss
gucken was in lg smart lg smart tryer was was ist an dem smart das muss ich mir
jetzt angucken was ist an einem wäschetrockner smart
koopa sehe ich auch so ich habe noch so eine oldschool mikrowelle wieder ich
habe mir als wir umgezogen sind 2013 hatte ich eine neue mikrowelle gekauft
von amazon in die miele oder so also nicht ganz so billiges ding und die hat
nach zwei jahren den geist aufgegeben jetzt habe ich wieder die alte mikrowelle
am start die hatten wir noch im dachboden stehen die alte mikrowelle auch mit auch
mit drehknopf und drehen in drinnen das ist easy as fuck power einstellen
dauereinstellen knopf drücken fertig ja sehe ich auch so so diese diese ich
sag mal analog mikrowellen waren gar nicht so verkehrt ok was genau kann denn
jetzt bitteschön ein smart tryer ok wi-fi capable
wi-fi enable tryer
ok es sieht innen aus wie ein stink normaler trockner
aber er ist smart und inwiefern ist er smart es sieht auch von hinten aus wie
normaler trocken er sieht allgemein aus wie normaler trockner einfach wie ein
stink normaler trockner zwar ein bisschen fancy gebaut aber ansonsten aus wie
trockner so also was kann er denn die art of es ich
brauche kein fucking design trockner ich will einfach einen trockner
warte mal ich kann jetzt gar nicht nachgucken was ich für ein trockner
habe ich habe auch neuen trockner bestellt bei amazon damals als wir hier
umgezogen sind also bezüglich als wir ins haus eingezogen sind und ich habe den
den trockner damals bei amazon bestellt inklusive aufstellen zwar echt geil die
amazon dudes sind gekommen oder die die speditionstippen die beauftragt wurden
die sind die sind reingekommen haben die alte waschmaschine runter den den alten
trockner runter aber ich denn für scheiß doch den alten runter getragen den
neuen hochgetragen das war häse was ergibt keinen sinn was ich jetzt erzähle
ich habe vorher ich hatte vorher gar kein trockner
die waschmaschine ich habe euch miss erzählt die waschmaschine habe ich bei
amazon bestellt die waschmaschine haben die hochgetragen haben die alte waschmaschine
runtergetragen und sogar angeschlossen und das hat irgendwie nur 30 euro auf preis
gekostet bei amazon den trockner habe ich dann auch bei amazon bestellt mit bis
zum aufstellungsort den haben die auch die treppe hochgetragen und angeschlossen
also kannst du kannst dich echt nicht beschweren gut das anschließen wäre nicht
wichtig gewesen aber das aber das treppe hoch und runter tragen war wichtig
ok warum ist er smart was was kann das ding dann smart das wird so typische
kokona einheit 9.0 cubic feet also quadrat den ich quadrat fußvolumen auf
deutsch was ist cubic fußvolumen
raum fuß was ist das auf deutsch ich hab keine ahnung
cubic foot ok es ist volumen es ist hoch 3 es ist volumen
cubic fuß ok das heißt ist das nächste mal werde ich wenn ich jemand verwirren
will werde ich einfach die raumangabe in cubic fuß machen so geil die abi einheiten
seid mal froh dass es keine cubic ounces oder sowas gibt
hey leute meine lieblingseinheit meine lieblingseinheit ist immer noch betu pro
stunde beste betu pro stunde und betu durch stunde besser gesagt beste beste
einheit aller Zeiten auch auf deutsch betu die british thermal unit ist ein
einer so blabla genau genau betu ist definiert als die wärme energie die
benötigt wird um ein britisches fundwasser um ein grad fahren halt zu
erwärmen
das ist wirklich best of bullshit einheit in einer kombination alter und
ihr werdet lachen ihr würdet jetzt denken wer verwendet denn sowas sowas
wird immer noch gerne bei usw verwendet für ich glaube ich bin ich ganz sicher
was ist für was es bei usw steht ich glaube für das was die usw selber
verbraucht also sprich wenn du eine usw anstöpselst und das was du quasi
vorne rein pumpen musst und bei usf aus doch bei usf aus kann auch sein dass es
bei klima geräten auslöser bei usf aus auch was du quasi vorne rein pumpen
musst und wie viel davon hinten rauskommt für die geräte zur verfügung
steht betu das bei usf aus wird es verwendet
ja zum beispiel meine cyber power usw hatte das in betu stehen
betu pro stunde hatten sie das sogar glaub stehen hier guck 100 112 betu pro
stunde alles klar
oh man gut weiter wo bin ich jetzt darauf gekommen überhaupt von dem video
hier ich wollte gucken was an dem smart ist was ist denn an dem smart full touch
on door control ganz ehrlich ich bin da kein großer fan von wenn man trockner
wenn ich noch nasse hände habe oder so weil ich vielleicht vorhin irgendwie
andere wäsche in der hand hatte wenn ich das touchscreen mit meinem finger bedienen
muss warum nicht warum nicht einfach buttons zwar ganz im ernst warum nicht
einfach knöpfe kennst du die steinkohle einheit ne
tubo stream
an liege der potential of laundry innovative alter entfessel das potential
der wäsche innovation was heißt laundry eigentlich eins zu eins übersetzt
wäsche ok stimmt sogar was ich gesagt habe entfesseln das potential der
wäsche innovation
sink you sink you kann man aussprechen ergonomisch engel door ok das muss
natürlich äußerst smart sein dass das dass das tor in einem ergonomischen
winkel ist ok ich habe ehrlich gesagt nicht erkannt was an der sache jetzt
super smart ist habt ihr jetzt verstanden was ist daran ist so toll so
toll und smart
ja der preis ist smart ja das stimmt was kostet das lg signature 9.0
ok ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken ich muss mal kurz mein handy holen und mal
meinen trockner suchen ich muss mal gucken was mein trockner kostet
ok
wieder am start ich muss mal kurz gucken was mein drucker kostet er nicht
drucker was lame ich dann trockner trockner trockner your orders trockner
hoffe ich habs bei amazon bestellt no search found fast
try ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass ich den bei amazon bestellt habe
nee
ich habe ich habe ok ich suche mal nach was mit wärmepumpe ich weiß dass mit
wärmepumpe ist wärme da ist er doch siemens wt 4 6 w 261 der ist nicht smart
der ist nicht smart und kostet nur einen bruchteil davon ok das ding eine
nachfolger trock trockner und waschmaschine habe ich von amazon
iq 700 big brain leute nur zum glück zum glück habt ihr habt ihr so viel
subscribt in letzter zeit sonst wäre das hätten wir nicht iq 700 erreicht ja und
der kann der ist absolut nicht smart auch wenn der iq 700 hat oder funktioniert
einfach und kostet nur ein viertel davon ja ok jetzt kommen wir das video mal
kurz fertig wenn ihm die familie zu nervig wird dann versteckt er sich
bestimmt in dem raum und bastelt an dem equipment rum
was er hat er hat 5 er dieses ding finden total viele geil und ich weiß
nicht warum
warum finden die die unify treemachine alle so geil ich meine selbst wenn man
unify access points hat ich finde dieses unify zeug an sich gar nicht mal so
geil die access points sind gut aber die unify bedienung finde ich jetzt net so
der wahnsinn also mir wäre es tatsächlich immer noch lieber jeder
meine access point hat ein stink normales webinterface
edge router habe ich auch ich habe ja auch keine edge router ich habe auch mein edge switch
allein schon weil er eben ein eigenes firewall was glaube ich eine eigene
filmgeschichte mit webinterface hat das muss ich übrigens auch noch machen meine
unify access points liegen aktuell auf dem boden und das merke ich weil ich
nicht richtig in keller mitkommen würde ich die ordentlich an die decke hängen
im erdgeschoss dann hätte ich auch im keller guten empfang besseren empfang
betten jedes mal wenn die frau da reingeht in den raum weil sie irgendwas
da drin machen muss was ich wäsche aufhängen oder so wird sie ihm erzählen
wann machst du denn endlich dein kabelsalat mal ordentlich oder so was in
der richtung wer weiß was die stelle jedes mal jedes mal geht kann ich wetten
oder oder oder wie lange bleibt das denn so soll das denn jetzt etwa für immer so
bleiben noch mal also die haben den wohnzimmer mit fernseher und die haben
quasi noch mal ein extra fernsehraum exzellent das ist ein beamer das ist ein
beamer und das ist die leinwand da oben
ok die normalen den normalen fernsehraum haben die dazu da weißt was ich wenn die abends da sitzen und die kochen hinten und die kinder sind am start die kinder sitzen
dann vorne auf dem sofa gucken fernseh und abends können sich da ist eigentlich eine
coole sache mir werden zwei räume dedicated für fernseh zu viel weil ich
gucke ja im prinzip so gut wie kein fernseh aber so mit familie und so kann
ich das schon nachvollziehen warum wir das gebaut haben
das sieht bequem aus
aber cool sind die sind die sessel
der master bedroom so so noch ein fernseh was sonst
sind die tv in der bett und die sind übelst war weg allah
aber ich habe die use the fire tv in zum echo devices spiekers so wie die
spiegel ist mit hessner los ich mache eventuell demnächst werbung für
hessner ein bisschen bis ins bis ins sehr laut modus aktivieren
oft
und sie ist diejenige, die die Kamera hält.
Sie macht viel Behind-the-Scenes-Work
und wir arbeiten auf all diese Videos zusammen.
Wir werden Videos editieren
und wir werden hier auf der Kante sitzen,
diskutieren, was wir für euch machen wollen.
Wir haben hier auch eine TV mit HueSync,
wo wir die Videos, die wir editieren, reviewn können.
Wir haben hier einige Ikea Smart Shades
und diese arbeiten mit ZigBee.
Wir werden hier Smart Lighting und Automationen haben,
um uns während des Tages produktiver zu sein,
wo wir am Computer sein werden
und viel Arbeit machen wollen.
Aber wir schauen uns das Studio an,
wo wir viel Content filmen werden.
Das ist das Studio-Ruhm.
Das ist nur für mich.
Ihr müsst euch jetzt merken, der Schall,
der hat ja so Akustik-Dinger,
der Schall, der geht nicht hier an die Wand,
der Schall geht explizit da rein.
Der Schall weiß genau, er darf nicht da hingehen,
sondern er muss da hingehen.
So ist es. Der Schall geht nicht nach da,
nicht nach da, der Schall geht nur dahin.
Das sieht jetzt vielleicht bescheuert aus,
aber das kann schon seinen Sinn haben,
dass er sich hier hinstellt zum Aufnehmen und Erzählen.
Das kann schon sein.
Allgemein sieht der Raum doch auch ein bisschen gedämmt aus.
Okay, so viel hat man diesmal eher nicht gesehen.
Leute, ich hab Hunger.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir die restlichen Videos noch geguckt kriegen.
Ich werd jetzt, es ist dreieinhalb Stunden,
ich wollt heute eigentlich noch ein Video aufnehmen für YouTube
zum Thema Teilzeitarbeiten,
weil das einige immer mal wieder fragen
und ich dachte, ich erzähl da mal wieder was zu.
Das wird aber eng, das muss ich jetzt aufnehmen.
Ich muss jetzt was spachteln und dann schnell, schnell mitmachen.
Hatte ihr mal eine gute Idee für mein erstes Smart Home Projekt?
Ja, aber nichts Konkretes.
Ich kann dir nur raten, fang mit dem an,
was dir wirklich Arbeit erleichtert oder Sachen abnimmt,
die nervig sind, weil nur dann sieht man den Mehrwert.
Wenn man mit den Standardsachen anfängt,
was weiß ich, viele Leute fangen mit RGB-Beleuchtung an
oder sowas, und du brauchst zu 90% überhaupt kein RGB,
dort wo Lampen sind, dann ist das sinnlos,
dann sieht das jetzt einfach nur Spielerei.
Du musst mit irgendwas anfangen, was dir wirklich Arbeit abnimmt.
Von einer Statusanzeige, ob der Zug zu spät kommt,
bis eine Statusanzeige, ob die Wäsche fertig ist oder was auch immer.
Irgendwie was, was dir wirklich einen Mehrwert bringt,
dann bleibst du nämlich auch dabei und guckst halt,
dass das sinnvoll ausgebaut wird.
Wenn man einfach nur macht, um es zu machen,
ist das cool, aber verliert relativ schnell den Reiz.
So, ich wollte euch den Frasier hosten, aber der ist nicht da.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, wen ich hosten kann.
Keiner da, von denen ich Folge dies nötig hätten.
Okay, also Leute, machts gut, wir sehen uns,
bis dann, see you.